what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome
auntie I just wanted to clap oh yeah
welcome to the channel Auntie um before
we start don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and ring that notification
Bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in today we are going
to be reacting to my London hate group
did you know I have a hate group
as well yeah so there's some girls that
have been on the show and they kind of
embarrass themselves I'm not gonna lie
to you you know you've seen them do this
right I've seen them and I've heard you
stopped the woman I've heard you stop
one of them and say you know you'll just
keep on giving us this information we
haven't asked you for anything you're
the one who keeps talking and she still
didn't stop talking yeah so tell them
tell them what happened this week Auntie
this week I couldn't believe it I got
told I was rude that I was horrible
there was a there was a clip out there
even my granddaughter saw it and Auntie
Jenny is so Ruden she looks at me and
she said Grandma they're saying you're
rude I said no that's not grandmother
for Auntie Jenny they think Auntie
Jenny's Rich you know Grandma's not rude
she said you should teach them some
manners
Kobe can you believe it my manager's
here too guys I absolutely can't believe
it
so they decided to go on this podcast
and giving our side of the story we're
also gonna edit in the parts of the
podcast that they're talking about and
you guys can determine if we're rude
we're misogynistic if I said the girl
was confused was I wrong
we gotta wait okay show them show them
the clip blessing he passed that he
pressed that button with some SASS
and a lot of women that go on her
podcast they all have the same
experience so I do think that she's
quite anti-women and I think especially
um if like ethnic women now I'd like to
say after the podcast the girl in the
middle
said I don't want to be involved in any
controversy now I just want to see her
face in the middle does she look like
she does not want to be involved
the recruitment yeah so it's really hard
when somebody can't say the word ethnic
and when they come onto the show and
they say oh when you go in there and
she's anti-women we are not anti-women
how can we reactant women when we are
women our mothers are women our
grandparents are women our grandmothers
are women aunties are women so we're not
anti-women maybe it comes across like
that I personally am anti-dum
with women that is what I'm anti right
so if you want to say that I'm
anti-women make it clear I am anti dumb
women I am anti
[Music]
yes I am anti dumb
women and also I'm an ethnic woman yeah
I want to give a little um pretext to
the to the audience so this is the
domino effect podcast
um Eddie and Daly on the right
um Eddie did recruiting for us for a bit
and they have their own podcast we're
friends with them the guys on the left I
think I met once they've been on our
show and the girls in the middle both
came on my show as well everything I've
heard she said women shouldn't vote
correct me if I'm wrong
because they don't they shouldn't have
the right to vote because they don't
know what they want for dinner
well you can look at them
[Music]
and I was I said look at it look at most
girls don't know what they want for
dinner so how the hell are we going to
choose the leader of the Free World
exactly but I think what she's trying to
say is that she knows what she wants for
dinner so she confirms no no but
actually no what I said was that women
we don't get drafted the same and so
like in the US we have something called
Selective Service yeah and women aren't
enrolled in that and that basically
means if there's like a time of War like
men have to go in the draft Yeah and
historically that's why women didn't
vote was because we couldn't be drafted
and I said if we're going to vote let's
make it equal yeah and if you're going
to make it equal I wouldn't want to vote
that's what I said I would give it up if
I don't want to go to war I don't want
to fight yeah so I want them in that if
you don't want equality you go for it
but I don't want it I don't want it
because I don't want to go to wall I
know I will be cooking I swear to God up
in the kitchen I'll be on the floor
scrubbing the floor I'll do anything
rather than go pick up a gun and go out
there and shoot no no so if that means
equality and you have the right to vote
well I don't want equality because I
don't want to vote because I don't want
to get drafted women shouldn't vote
because women make emotional decisions
which means that when um politicians are
trying to sweep perspectives it's easy
to manipulate women into one way or
another of course means that when you're
making bigger decisions for the country
the people in power are swayed by people
who don't make decisions based on logic
okay
let me just show you
and they interrupted US during the show
and then they go on somebody else's show
and they don't know anything about
podcasts
etiquette oh and that's the thing the
guy on the left was trying to talk and
they talk over everyone and they both
did that on my own show and then they'll
say that they weren't given enough time
to explain yourself I'm like how much
time do you need someone shut up no and
that's what you'll do watch every time
the guys try to stand up for us or make
a point or say something they interrupt
or they try to interrupt every single
time and I'm like how not self-aware are
you
the same way let me shut you down
emotions let me shut you down
let me shut you down yeah and it's their
show that's the that's the crazy thing
cool thing it's based on your hormones
right naturally there's some women with
higher testosterone levels naturally so
naturally some women don't make
emotional decisions some yes so now hold
up hold up now because of that do you
see the guy in the lab
s is that whenever you go on a podcast
you're always talking about the majority
they might be minorities out there they
might be an exception to the rule we
ain't got time to go into deception of
the rule we are always going to talk
about the majority it's always going to
be about the majority is your IQ level
it's you that information and seeing
what's right for the country right there
are men with lower IQ than a lot of
women yeah I hear that so if some if
women are making emotional decisions in
your basement because some might react
in a certain way and they can't they'll
they might be swayed there's also men
with low IQ okay and let me just jump
how many members of lower IQ are running
countries out there exactly yeah so one
of the reasons why behind the idea of
the four is the perfect thing to look is
that is finances here so women own
two-thirds of Consumer Debt why is that
because women are easier to sway in One
Direction or another so you're gonna
have people who we all know that men
have more money than women generally
yeah but women make the majority of
consumer decisions even though the have
less money and you're going to leave
them to make decisions for the country
no that and that's not okay
she's doing it again Daddy's trying to
talk The Host the host of the podcast
and she doesn't let him talk and guys
this is what she did the whole show I
swear to God the whole show
I'll tell you why you're saying because
like it's just the thing yeah a man now
a man now yeah like obviously someone
have beef and whatever and won't jump on
a podcast because of someone I think
these are the guys from Birmingham yeah
they are yeah oh yeah but for me yeah
you're saying you wouldn't have jumped
on because of pill that's answer I gotta
say the man on the right watches
Expressions while they're talking he's a
comedian watch his Expressions when the
women start talking rubbish
I'll tell you why why because I like
podcasts a podcast is about
conversations right and it's about it's
not having big she didn't have a
conversation she got on the show and she
spilled her guts yeah and you told her
she was like why do you what I remember
you saying why are you keep on talking
she spilled her guts it's like damn near
a therapy session it was like she told
this whole story and why do I know this
about about her baby father about and
it's like what will happen is I'll ask a
general question and if there's
something too private that you don't
want to share don't share it but if you
if you tell the story and then we ask
more questions you can't be offended
because you told the story like I've
been on podcasts where like people have
asked me a question and I just say next
question I don't want to answer that oh
I say that's not my story to tell yeah
yeah but you don't get on there and just
spill your guts and then complain
because people know all your business
and then try and backtrack that's
exactly what they're doing I'm gonna
call her away to views it's about being
able to sit there and explain each other
and everyone taking on that concept and
understanding it's an exchange of words
right I used those subjects a big
interview to you it's bigger should I
tell you why her following is a cult
following I'm part of you're part of a
cult I have joint a cult no how come you
didn't tell me I was joining the cult
I'm like wow it's a cult that's crazy
what is the definition of a cult okay a
cold is a system of religious veneration
and Devolution directed towards a
particular figure object oh definition
two a person or thing that is popular or
fashionable among a particular group or
sexual Society I'll be worshiping you
then you're the cult leader I guess I
don't
hold up hold up let me finish she's
coming in she's coming we
how unaware are you this is the least
self-aware okay I want you to like count
I swear to God and she's gonna watch
this she's gonna get mad don't care
um I want you to look at the podcast you
were on with me and look at this podcast
and count every time you start talking
time it time it and count what percent
of the podcast on a group of six you
talk when you are not the host and you
know what the girl next door I want you
to do it too because you talk damn near
the whole podcast on my show too and
then I'm the bad guy okay he's coming in
because and I'll tell you why because
I'm a very reasonable person and if you
what does she sound like a reasonable
person she's not listening to anyone
she's not allowing anybody else to talk
I'm still waiting for her to land on
landed I landed from Gatwick on Friday
on Saturday quicker than she's Landing
Now podcast you won't even be able to be
mad at me because you will see I'm being
very fair Eddie was I not being there I
was being to the fair and she took my
and she tried manipulating it to go for
her cult following is she talking about
the clips what is she saying here she's
talking about the show where she
embarrassed herself which she would not
have it manipulated it's two and a half
hours unedited some people see I don't
know it was like I'm trying to remember
her show exactly I remember it's hard
because that's why I think we're gonna
edit it in or something but basically
what happened was she came on the show
and she told this story about her like
her husband at the time she left him
because he might cheat like he said I
might cheat and then it was like oh
we're not together now but we'll be
together later my child's fine and then
she was saying how she was not a
feminine woman then but she's a feminine
woman now and I said well how like if
you're a feminine woman like what have
you done because there's this it's not
just her like a lot of times girls come
on the show and they think it's just
them that I'm basing these conclusions
on but there's a whole group of like
YouTubers that they're like femininity
coaches or they talk about being
feminine and they've done no work they
just say they're feminine one day
they're like oh I'm feminine now and I'm
like okay well have you been in a
relationship where that guy will co-sign
that you're feminine and you've been
practicing it right have you been
learning to cook like what specifically
have you done like you still work you
just watched a few YouTube videos I
think the thing that stood out was she
started off talking and talking and
talking and talking and talking and then
suddenly she mentioned she had a child
yeah that's that's the bombshell she
didn't like the way she didn't like the
way it switched because we're all giving
her advice as a single married woman and
then all of a sudden it was like and my
child she sort of slipped that she had a
child in there and then the whole
conversation changed and she didn't like
him yeah and then um so Carnival is like
a crazy Festival here right and you saw
the video I did and so she talked about
and I think she's going to talk about
this she talked about how she went to
she went to Carnival which at first it
was like you're a single woman but how
are you traditional and you're at
carnival right and I don't claim to be
like the epitome of traditional women
however like I only went to Carnival to
do interviews and like I'm sorry the
women that I know that are the most
feminine and the most traditional you
could not oh my God my dog
um you could not not too many Housewives
at a carnival no no but the thing is is
that for Pearl it was like a culture
shock but women married women do codes
of Carnival traditional women they do go
to Carnival but what they do is that
they make sure if you're going to go to
Carnival you there's two days to go to
Carnival there's children's day and
there's the adults day so if I'm going
to take a child if I'm going to go to a
carnival by myself as a married woman I
would either go with my man on a Monday
or unless you're in a band you'd go on a
Sunday so you do take children on a
Sunday but you get them home before
bedtime yeah I have a sneaking suspicion
she didn't bring her kid to the kids day
one well she can't just she contradicted
herself and that's what happened like
she would tell these stories and then
later like I would be like okay this
doesn't make sense but like like that's
what would happen if she because I was
listening and then later she would say
things that kind of like contradicted
herself yeah and then I would be like
okay I'm just being real with you you
hear I didn't make you say this this is
based on the words that came out of your
mouth this isn't making sense and then
she's like you manipulated me but the
thing is like modern women are so used
to not having pushback for anything that
they don't even realize how delusional
they sound like she I bet you she has no
idea she talks for 60 70 of a podcast
with 10 people on it you'd be surprised
no I tried she said it she says it on
him that she talked mostly she thanked
you for giving her all that time on the
show oh okay let's see so her men can be
like yeah that girl's chatting [ __ ] yo
man I don't know what you're saying
because the words that you say you can
only use that is unless she edited the
words yeah yeah and you could hear that
there's words being cut out no
that's a lie before we use if you watch
the full podcast you will see nothing
was clipped she wish it was clipped to
make her look good but nothing was
clipped and even after it was clipped
but I always say to people that when you
see things like this go and watch the
whole podcast before you make a decision
based on five minutes did you see okay
for example for example if I say when I
go out on the streets men approach me
right does she look approachable and
then she said that men will grab in
Morocco but she actually said it next to
Moroccan who pulled her up about it
because the men weren't grabbing her the
men were approaching her because she's
in a tourist area is obviously she
looked like that then she switched and
said even when I go home to India but
obviously you don't trust traditional
look at her Indian women do not expose
themselves like that when you go to
Morocco people go to Morocco as tourists
but if you there's some places you go to
where it's safer and it's more more
traditional for women to cover yourself
up if you look at some of the um female
reporters when they go certain places
they will put on the scarf they will
cover up themselves I'm not saying all
men I'm saying men I get more approach
she might not get approached the way I
get approached yeah because you're so
out of shape
they might not find her attractive many
reasons yeah what are the reasons Phil
give us a reason you're not attractive
Phil and again her cult follows one of
the reasons is not because you're away
you'll find me unattracted attractive
but her beautiful
she knows that I'm now me too me too all
men I'm saying that all men harass me
I'm not saying we always talk in a
majority she didn't say that some men
harass her she said all men harasser I
mean she's she's casting a vision for
society where she can't even go in
public yes she can't even go in public
and that was the point I was making was
she was saying like everywhere I go
these people approach me and I'm like
you realize like and I I don't remember
off the top of my head but I believe I
said something along the lines of like
this is why men will say you're me
tooing everyone because because you're
you're casting a certain light on men
and I'm just saying that's a shitty way
to look at men I agree and I don't I
don't think like I wouldn't want to be
Associated if they said oh I can't go
anywhere like women are always touching
me like like that that's a shitty light
on woman yeah and I just think like you
need to be careful about the things that
you say yeah and especially if you're
going to generalize about a group of
people and I I really wish I knew the
time stamps of that video because I'd
like to pull it up but we can we could
go back to it later is this a clip
that's many Clips
oh did you did you inter shout out to my
content team in Nigeria yeah shout out
Chris Shout Out Chris
he pulls lots of clips from you mean you
have ethnic people doing your videos
yeah yeah wow yeah yeah doesn't matter
obviously to us
did she say you're saying oh man a
person says that she said she then
labeled it this woman is me doing all
men I want a thumbnail yes because
that's on YouTube
if I know I don't like if someone came
on my podcast said I know I'm doing a
genuine podcast by the way she hasn't
got a podcast yet I will not manipulate
for clickbait I don't do that wait she
doesn't have a podcast no she says she's
gonna have one oh I thought she had a
podcast no she doesn't the other girl
has she will say later on oh yeah
I would say anyone that comes I love I
love people that have never done the job
and just think they can do it better
they're really Pleasant let me let me go
up to Jeff Bezos and tell him how to run
an Amazon but the thing is what she
doesn't realize like she's got the
perfect pod whatever you say for us in
our thumbnails we'll just Elevate and we
might of course for example when you
came in and said your dad had two wives
yeah we said oh your dad had two wives
what you said yeah we didn't say like
this woman Advocates that every man
should have exactly is that he's
spinning exactly yeah
there's only one aspect to it the other
important bit is what you actually see
and that's yeah and that's what I said
to you like it's important as a
podcaster it's a skill a lot of people
think you just come here and talk yeah
it's your ability to control The
Narrative of the conversation
but also and again maybe this is where
the cultural differences are when it
comes to even like me traveling as an
Asian woman they don't see me as my
British passport they see me as an Asian
woman if I go to Dubai they see me as a
Bangladeshi woman and they will take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you
grew up in the like like um you said
well I think you said Morocco yeah
majority I'll say this the context on in
which this happened you were on holiday
right you're right about the pillow I
I've noticed I'm Banning them from the
show and you're saying that people
grabbed you what was the context of that
group no I'm not saying that they're
constantly grabbing I've seen this
approach the constantly trying to talk
yeah is changing yeah I'm changing
further back before another entry you
can be quite shy and introvert me
personally I'm very very shy but when
you are in a situation where you feel
comfortable you can come out of your
shell and with some guys you know with
some girls they can come out their shell
whereas other women have made them feel
no you stay shy because women
I don't think that I think guys will
approach you if they feel good about
themselves so if they feel like they're
you know put pushing gym or whatever
that to build their own self-confidence
I I know guys that feel good about
themselves like they're like yeah I'm
good looking I go to the gym you know
I'm a nice person and he won't approach
a girl but he'll look at a girl and be
like no I won't approach her because we
we like or that girl looks so good and
this is this is the death of femininity
I think a lot more women are masculine
because back in the day women would
signal and even when we had kit on the
other day he he educates women yeah he
educates women how to signal to allow a
man to to go comfortable enough to get
um to approach against the interesting
maybe the problem is men aren't actually
looking for women's signal before
they're approaching so when a girl is
now calling Paw Patrol is because she's
not signaled to you she's not showed you
she's any interested you don't know what
her relationship status is and maybe
wait for the cues for a woman
she's trying to talk you and
you want to talk you and her every
single time I don't know if anyone else
sees his tfl regularly maybe I'm poor
but you know go on the tube you see the
advert
um stare and harassment
it puts men on edge yeah
to like countries where there isn't that
a lot of men take advantage so it's not
these aren't put in there for women do
the majority of men are the majority of
men the men you're describing sorry of
the majority of men Dominion describing
so the men you're saying that take
advantage is that in the country like
where this isn't the social Norm just
answer the question where you have to
but is that the majority of men sorry is
that do you so the majority of yeah gone
do you think the majority of men are
doing that in those countries in those
countries what going up to women
unsolicited yeah 100 normal okay boom
majority amen
home
the majority of men approach
the majority
much better she meets
the majority of men is that Kobe Kobe is
that
is that is that much better than all men
it's not taken out of context at all I
mean you could literally just put quote
majority of men end quote in developing
countries or sex offenders that's what
she's saying you know what you know what
hold up hold up I'm gonna
Zariah if you're watching this I'ma
switch it for you I'm gonna put
the majority just to make it a little
more accurate maybe I see where you're
coming from yeah maybe I
see the majority of men you're right so
she's like there's like a 10 of men that
are just so socially anxious they won't
approach anybody the other 90 are all
vicious yep vile you know she is me too
and the thing is how many times how many
times was that question asked how many
times to get to the answer Yeah Eddie
asked the question you watch the
Christian I'm sure idiots a couple of
times you asked a couple of times before
she actually came up with an answer
the majority of men in those countries
are grabbing girls 100
100
their own grave 100 you the majority of
men you know what grabbing girls I would
like to say this you are a misandrist I
swear to God you can say that you
believe in equality you can say you
believe in all this [ __ ] but when you
say it when you say [ __ ] like that that
is open Miss Andrea against men and I
don't stand for that [ __ ] I have
brothers I have fathers my dad I employ
people in other countries my dad I grew
up around people that were employed from
other countries and including India
which is one of the countries that she
talked about and that is open missandry
that is open with Andrew that is not how
men are that is not how the majority of
men are and you saying that is open with
Sandra against men and and women if if a
woman did the same thing or if if a man
did the same thing about women people
would have a Heyday but you can come on
a podcast and just freely speak blatant
sexism as my mom say she always attracts
flies pretty of men in those countries
are committing assault yes that's your
view on men no no that's okay okay and
so then I clarified it even more just to
be sure you're saying the majority of
men in those countries commit assault
and she said yes yes
poor women over there all those women
over there get get interviews by all of
those men every single man and her
evidence for it is she walked down a
street one time and one person did
something no no
all the men were going through wherever
she went in India all the men the
majority the majority of men were going
for the majority men were grabbing her
wherever she went she went to India they
grabbed her she can't go anywhere
without a man grabbing her in India they
do I will say I have been to India they
do come up to you a lot but it's like I
remember when I went to India and this
is this is the difference of like the
two type of the type of woman you can be
I went to India and I had a great time I
was called Beautiful more than I've ever
been called beautiful in my life they
didn't grab me they were just like oh
you're so beautiful you're so because
there aren't many like white people in
India so they're like oh your skin your
hair you're beautiful you're beautiful
you're beautiful everywhere and I'm not
gonna say oh I was assaulted oh this
this and this no they give you a
compliment now look it I was I a trap I
mean I was 18 at the time but was I
attracted to most of the men that did
that no but can you say assault I'll say
thank you I went to Tenerife and the
same thing happened to me wherever I
went I kept on getting approached but
what she's not saying is that when you
go to these places of tourist and you
get approached all the time they want to
sell you you something they want to show
you something true actually and they
always want to sell you something
whatever I went in Morocco yeah and
they've always got something in Morocco
it's sunglasses you know do you want
sunglasses do you want this whatever you
want they will approach you all the time
I could not walk along the seafront
without being approached about 10 times
did I think I was really attractive that
all these men are approaching me no they
were selling stuff but what she said is
yes to majority of men being assaulters
yeah that was the word assault they were
grabbing her that is completely
different then yeah I switched it for
you you know yeah she maybe that was two
maybe that was too click B I don't know
I don't know I switched it to the
majority okay you're welcome you're
welcome and man that's cultural
differences in my country even where
women's rights are not like well I'm not
I'm not here saying women are equal to
me I'm saying but if a woman doesn't
want to be touched don't touch her
that's even a religious side if you
don't touch it I'm with you yes I think
I've Got a Feeling trauma's gonna come
up in them countries where what
countries even parts of Asia Africa can
you name them
what they'll do they'll make
man is this manipulative to say when you
okay this is happening in these
countries because normally half the time
when girls say this [ __ ] they've never
been to this country and I'll tell you
this was an educated moment that I had
in my life I always heard [ __ ] about
Saudi Arabia right I was always like I
always heard that it was horrible and I
interviewed zoobie like two years ago on
my channel for the first time and he
grew up in Saudi Arabia and he said it's
actually not that bad and he told me
things about Saudi Arabia I had no idea
about so if I went on a podcast and
started spewing [ __ ] about a country I'd
barely been to or maybe been to once or
you know I would look pretty ignorant I
went to Ghana I had a great time with
the locals I met some great men that
made some great friends no one
approached me nobody grabbed me
everybody was friendly like family Oh
Yes actually I love Ghana I actually
fitted in Uganda so when she's saying
even Africa they grab you the men were
very respectful let's see let's see what
country she says travel to yeah
I've had men approach me millions and
I've said no no no Millions can she
count Millions even if you go on holiday
for a week two weeks even if you go on
holiday for a year count it can you is
it possible to be approached millions of
times even if you had one a second one a
minute how long is that that she's gonna
get approached what makes her better
than me how come she gets a post about
millions of guys and I might get
approached by 10. and this is this is
the thing Auntie she could have just
said in this podcast you know what maybe
I misspoke yeah maybe I'm wrong but
modern women have this need to be right
at all costs Millions even even when
they're like oh I'm from Morocco and
she's got Moroccans sitting next to her
and she's still saying no no no no no
this has happened Millions
you said you said wait wait you said you
said grabbed they were they were right
even in Dubai they grabbed one of my
friends I've been to Dubai I was
and I went with my family family sorry
yeah
actual differences are when it comes to
even like me traveling as an Asian woman
they don't see me as my British passport
they see me as an Asian woman if I go to
Dubai they see me as a Bangladeshi woman
and they I don't believe that because
that she don't just like her if she
dressed like a Bangladeshi woman
normally does traditionally she wouldn't
get that but when you go with your
testing Lycra they're going to approach
you yeah and that's the other thing like
I've been to when I was 18 I went to
Italy and
um it was so hot that I was in like
shorts and literally like this is a
cultural difference we would go to see
the churches they would and I know I
didn't know I didn't know I didn't know
because they didn't care like that they
would just wave at you like get out yeah
yeah because you have to cover up it's
respectful I know I should have I don't
know I was 18 I just in the US
did the same thing yeah yeah but that's
that's the thing like different cultures
like different things are acceptable and
before you go somewhere find out what
the culture is but you can look at
pictures find out what the local women
are wearing find out the Traditions I
mean that's why a lot of people have
problems when they go to Dubai because
they don't find out what the culture is
When in Rome you know do as a Romans do
so you can't go somewhere and say well
you know because I've got a [ __ ]
passport I can do what I like no you
can't no and that's the thing like I
could have been married oh they're
discriminating against women
no no no
it was real hot Auntie it was so hot I
bet you look hot as well in a church in
shorts how dare you it's funny but when
you go to some Churches in the Caribbean
you know and you're not covered I've
been to certain churches and it says oh
no they get a scarf and cover your head
yeah you know yeah they cover my head
when I go in and then you go in the
church you realize that all the women
said to cover that just in case you're a
visitor rather than offend you which
they do sometimes when they cover my
head they just cover your head take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
because I know a couple couple people
from those countries and they don't
actually have the same views as you grew
up in the like like um I wish you'd stop
saying 100 she should stop saying 100
interrupts you every time you talk on
every fix 100 100 you know a lot of
people will get me for that mm-hmm
because that's what I do
um that sounds like a black thing it's a
black thing some a lot of black people
like I'm listening but I know it doesn't
but it's okay it's better than this 100
I think you said Morocco yeah
majority I'll say this the context in
which this happened you on holiday right
and you're saying that people grabbed
you what was the context of that group
no I'm not saying that they can't you
see it you see now she's been found out
she's like [ __ ] I'm next to an actual
Moroccan maybe she didn't expect some
Moroccan to look like that
approached the constantly trying to talk
yeah no no
do the majority of men assault now she's
switching it now she's switching it
because she realizes she said something
wrong instead of just saying I was wrong
she's gonna point the finger at Pearl
like I made you say this wild [ __ ] on my
podcast what can I say as a Moroccan
were you a tourist were you in a tourist
area were you in the Medina where
they're approaching you to sell you
things what because I'll just walk in
the beach I was walking the beach even
if it's a tour whenever you go on
holiday and there's a beach people are
going to approach you to show you
something wherever you go in the whole
world and I will say the majority of
places that you go to if you're on the
beach somebody will approach you at some
point to sell you something it's just
you just expect it area what I'm saying
is some countries like even just say
when I go Bangladesh and I'm not a
tourist yeah and I'm in my own country
clothes everything guys will still feel
like they can they have a right to come
and speak to you okay do you know
something right when you go to these
places as a married woman they show you
some respect when you go to India I've
got Indian friends you get you get
treated differently if you've left your
husband or if you're divorcee I've known
women to stay in a marriage even though
they're separated don't get divorced so
their children can go back and enjoy the
culture because sometimes you get
treated differently if you're a divorce
woman if you split up with your husband
or if you're a single parent you will
get treated differently in certain
cultures and that's the fact 100
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm saying
again look at social cues if like you
said the guys teaching girls what
signaling is if she's not making eye
contact if she's not don't maybe don't
approach her especially and that's how
you make her know what your signals are
according to where you're going because
certain signals are different in
different places that you go to it's for
you
about the situation that I was
describing because you're kind of like
me tooing these guys because they
approached okay can I just say as a
victim who has been sexually abused as a
drama old it's yeah it is deep it is
deep and I don't want if I don't I'm
sorry but
women can wear whatever they want to
wear I have no problem with women when
whatever they want to wear when you go
to certain places you need to be aware
of what you're wearing if you're
somebody that's been
and you still have issues with being
then you don't show you don't wear
clothes that shows every crease every
bit of flab every bit of Hangover every
part of your body you cover yourself up
you wouldn't want to put your body on
show so you can't put your body on show
and then claim that oh yeah I got abused
as a child you got abused as a child go
and get it sorted go and get the trauma
sorted you can't say oh these men
approached me and it was really bad
because I'd been if you know that you're
good if you know that you're suffering
from trauma and you know that people get
approached in these places do not go
cover yourself up do not wear tight
clothes that shows off everything and
then say oh I got a child and it affects
me everybody's got trauma now go and get
it sorted I'm sick of hearing about
people's trauma sick of it and it's like
this is the thing women come on my show
and they say some sob story and they
just expect to get a pass for all the
[ __ ] that they said yeah and it's like
you don't I'm sorry you don't get a pass
for open missandry against men because
you have trauma if you have trauma go
deal with it go to a therapist but all
of men should not have to have to pay
because you have opened Miss Andrea
against men because you have hatred for
the other gender and I'm sorry about
saying that the majority of men commit
assault that's open with Sandra and
that's hatred towards men and the thing
is is that because she hasn't dealt with
it that tarnishes her view you can't
trust of you in anything because she's
gonna come with a view of a traumatized
person so it's all off synced all of her
views you can't trust anything because
they're coming from a damaged
perspective and am I am I so mean here
I'm so terrible so mean terrible want
you accessing my personal space don't do
it
it's not just me talking to you no I
talk to everyone I'm a very social do
you see how she like switches it like
before it was there grabbing her and
then she's like I didn't say they
grabbed me and now she's gonna say it
but then she would then she will talk to
everyone I'm sorry but when I went to
Tenerife and I was being approached by
the other men it was like oh hi young
lady hi Miss how gorgeous would you I
said no thank you I mean maybe it's just
a definition of assault yeah
as somebody coming up and talking to you
then I might agree with her maybe we're
all getting assaulted 24 7. no she just
don't know if that's what assault is she
said once you invade a private space
that is it that's assault and now see
like this is you she's only proven my
point she's only proving my point even
further social you you trying to cross
that line no like if I'm not necessarily
the guy's fault because if he I
personally myself have been through the
same thing but I would never be able to
look at a guy and say you know it's your
fault if I'm getting mad that you're
coming up and talk to me I'm not saying
he does I love that girl she's doing so
much sense she was so sensible and sweet
and calm with it he doesn't know what's
happened to you so he shouldn't be able
to feel like too shy to still come true
you see it do you see how she's talking
and and you're still is it right because
I know she's gonna watch this
um you see how you're still interrupting
you're you're still interrupting but
everyone when you talk lets you talk you
notice the other two girls on the couch
they haven't even died because you've
been hogging
I will smile and I'll go on my way if he
is now following me and trying to take
advantage of that situation yes I will
panic and that how many men walk behind
you when you're going in the park they
want to get at the park as well
he understands oh she doesn't want to
say hello and he Minds his business
there's no problem
that's what it is but you said them if
you're trying to avoid a man do not
smile at him do not smile at him now
she's saying that she talks to anyone
yeah yeah she talks to everyone and she
smiles at them and then she's got a
problem with it she's
like
she's like oh no no you know assault am
I talking about salt they're talking
about the signals but she's already done
it she's smiling she's talking to them
she's giving out those signals I like
how the other girl she was so big she's
like you know the same and that's what
she wasn't ready for she wasn't ready
for a girl saying had the same
experience as her but dealt with her
trauma yeah I'm sorry like the world
doesn't owe you for your trauma I'm
sorry that something bad happened to you
but it's your job to go figure it out or
let it affect you the rest of your life
and you can't allow it to affect other
people and that's what she's doing she's
not letting it affect all the men she's
tarnishing all the men because of her
walked for you majority of men are
grabbing girls
and that's and that's where like I have
an issue with that because I I can you
always hear me in the background saying
you're saying the majority it's not the
maturity okay it's all saying that I
kept on saying it I kept on saying it
don't think you're correct I know people
from those countries and they would not
say the same thing so it's interesting
thing to me that's your view because it
to me that's like that's like your view
on men
I'm not saying that it doesn't happen
I'm not saying it doesn't happen we're
saying did you see how you started
talking okay okay but
let me get over there then
but I manipulated her and it's crazy
you have to talk to manipulate something
yeah the majority okay it happens
okay Soraya as you watch this I know you
will did you did you interrupt Auntie
too so let me let me just count how many
people she's interrupted me she's
interrupted the girl next to her she's
interrupted the other girl on the couch
she's interrupted you not Eddie yeah but
she she's so pleasant on podcast she's a
lovely one
it and it might be my figure it might be
my and that's why again
oh wow I like to when I go especially
abroad I don't wear clothes that will
extenuate my figure as much or my skin
because I like to protect myself yeah it
might be that they find me attractive
and they want to maybe every girl
doesn't experience that but every time I
go out I do get approach so I do get
both into and I have sorry
sorry Auntie
every time she goes up I'd like to go
out with her and record this all right
here's a question for the panel Who Lies
more men about how many women they get
or women about how often guys approach
them or into them baby boy man that's
what I think do you know what I would
like to like guys definitely cap about
how many girls are into them or whatever
but I think women do it more but there's
another question Who Lies more about
their white men over women oh women okay
okay should we go back to the original
one I think I think we saw what we
needed yeah we did I think we saw what
we needed to see I mean you like it yeah
I do I mean I think she's not she knows
this but like you like her yeah I mean
because if poker like a poker like
anyone
honestly
but and and there's a lot of podcasts
that I have done for absolute free that
are way below me in subscriber because I
am thankful for people that came on
especially when I was building the show
yeah but it's like I can't stop you from
talking crazy
it's saying stuff that you don't want to
say that's on you yeah that's what he
says if you don't want anyone to know
about it basically shut your mouth
still interrupting yeah still
interrupting still talking over people
still interrupting about my experience I
do think like that no she doesn't think
she does not think she didn't know the
difference she doesn't think what
somebody says to you you know what is a
woman and you don't know you don't think
Hano itself it's like a bit anti-women
because panel uh like mine like the the
show panels we don't really have like
you know you don't have a there's only
panels of gas yeah yeah but I think
she's I think she's just saying the
podcast is anti-women you know it's like
why would she come on then if it's
anti-women oh she didn't oh she said I
didn't know it was empty room until they
got there when you say something she she
brings all these stats Yeah so basically
you confused her with the stats why
didn't you go with your feelings why
didn't you go with yourself it's gonna
be something she's lacking in her
argument yeah
and the thing is is that when I go to
church and if if the pastor says
something I will write it down and I
will go but I won't say yeah yeah I
believe him I will write it down in a
book and I can I've got years of them
every time I go to a church I write down
what they say and I want to go and look
for it for myself and I mean everybody
keeps announcing where did you get these
stats from why don't you say the stats I
know I always say Google it Google it
you wanna find out Google they're never
happy even if I give it to them like I
was on this podcast and they're talking
about body count and I was talking about
the data on body count they said where I
said the CDC the Center for Disease
Control and and they're still not happy
they're never happy now you make up
statistics how many times have you given
a fact and a guest changed their opinion
because the fact they're like you know
what I was wrong with point I just made
actually more than you'd think okay yeah
like I had a couple girls say they don't
believe they're feminists anymore I had
a couple
um I have it in a while because
the shows we've been doing are more like
they just haven't been geared this way
but like I didn't show and there was a
couple people that said they were going
to be pro-life after the show and the
thing is that it's not the majority I
would say maybe like 10 20 but even
pills none of us to you know be an
influence and changing them on and she's
wrong you've done that with zooby you
know I could remember you had a
percentage and when he explained himself
you were like you know what I'll give
you an extra 10 I think you said or
something like that so even pearls I
mean my view is like if you if you think
I'm saying something wrong prove me
wrong change my mind and prove me wrong
but don't say that I'm wrong but you
can't tell me where I'm going wrong you
know it's it's stupid and then stats you
prove like my conversation she was
saying that women are bad with money
yeah
I come from a black the guy just said
which they are she's still cutting
across still cutting across him and he
said women are bad with money background
like African women are the best with
money is that how you feel yeah no no
but listen to my words I'm saying do you
do your steps according to African women
Caribbean women white women American
women aren't the statues women in
general it's the women owned two-thirds
thirds of Consumer Debt worldwide
actually was looking into Nigerian women
um their credit card debt
um obviously credit card fraud no no no
no no no no no no no no no I couldn't
find much data on like specifically
Nigerian women because it was those you
know um I think that was one of the ones
she said
um what I found was like I think women
are locked out of credit card markets
there and I'm like maybe there's a
reason food there's a lot of fraud going
on that's why so that's why they have to
be good with cash okay is how you feel
though no it's not about how I feel my
reality women are very good what do the
stats say I don't feel but my reality
your reality is still your feelings
because not stats what are you gonna
back it up with my reality she doesn't
live in the reality because she doesn't
know what a woman is
it's his show shut up yeah that's the
how many y'all I know I know they're
gonna watch this and I just want you
both to know how many times have we
counted I can't even count how many
times you've interrupted hosts that's
right and then when I'm talking about my
point of view and then what I was
getting was in so in comments so
um it's Auntie Jenny that's me
I can be rude
thank you Eddie I love you Eddie
People You can disagree with someone's
opinion without like saying oh you're
just confused no if I'm asking you as a
woman what a woman is
and you're telling me that you bleed
three times a month
and then you questioned yourself and
said oh no I only bleed once come on you
don't know how many how much you believe
and then we'll explain to you about
biology and you are saying that being a
woman surely can't be a bad biology
being a woman is about feeling like a
woman so anyone that feels like a woman
can be a woman of course I'm gonna say
you're confused I still stick with that
you are confused you're upset with me
that you're confused because you are a
woman and you don't know what a woman is
now you're upset because I called you
confused look at the podcast you are
confused so this is this is social media
but even coming but no I feel like you
can just be like oh I hear what you're
saying I just don't agree because my
reactions
people want to watch this all the chat
[ __ ] we don't want that's what one
people want to see but even coming he's
right she did chat [ __ ]
they want to see the question your
podcast did you bring her Eddie's the
one that said that you recruited him and
they said that they yeah I think Eddie
recruited her right because know she was
going to be there just Attica to make
sure that people are not being insulted
it's etiquette not to interrupt people
when you're on a podcast you know
comments right her followers
nothing to do with pearl you are warned
about the super chess before you start
the show and if you make your own pot
always warns you if you make yourself
look like an idiot they will come for
you yeah I tell them before I always say
that super chats are mean if you don't
want somebody to know something pulses
don't say it don't say it so because if
they come at you purses it's not my
fault so she can't accuse Pearl because
you know that Pearl's gonna read out the
super chats everybody knows that Pearl's
gonna read out the super chats so how
can you blame Pearl for the super chats
you were acting stupid you acting
confused so of course she's gonna have
to say something I gotta say that
because she didn't know what a woman was
she did not know what a woman was so of
course I'm gonna say that she's
racist they were racist they said things
like why where did you bring this to
generate Nigerian women okay hang on
wait till after that he says something I
remember he says are you sorry no why is
that
racist they've called other people
they said you are degenerate and
Nigerian which is what the person said
but now because she's realized that
she's up there saying oh I'm Nigerian
now they realize she's a degenerate
Nigerian she's trying to make it sound
as if all we're saying all Nigerian
women no love I know some really good
Clipper Nigerian women you're the one
you're the one as the man said they are
talking about you and you know what I
feel like I feel like they they
clarified this because okay I feel like
it's because normally Nigerian women are
not degenerates like I think that's why
they said it was because like it's
abnormal they couldn't say like I like
I've had so many Nigerian women on their
show on the show and they're usually
like more submissive they're usually
very much believe in like respect to
their husbands and that sort of thing
but the thing is they couldn't say
degenerate woman otherwise that would be
bad for all women they couldn't say
degenerate black woman because otherwise
that would be for all women so they had
to say you are where did you get this
degenerate Nigerian from this
degenerative Nigerian not all of them
she must be the only Nigerian woman in
the whole world that doesn't know what a
woman is of course they're gonna say
that she does not know what a woman is
he's generating Nigerian women that's
suggesting now Nigerian women are they
said woman they didn't say women
generally no it's not but it's also
she's not representing just Nigeria
though you're just talking about she
come up there when all Nigerians are
proud to represent Nigeria everybody
comes on this oh I'm Nigerian I'm from
this this is my tribe they all do it
they all do it no I don't know it's like
the Obi tribe and then there's like two
people I mean you know better
or something yoga or Yoruba or something
and I I mean I Loosely know about it
because like literally there's so many
Nigerian people that have come on the
show and they're all so proud yes
if you just said oh I don't agree with
what this woman is saying fair enough
that's not reality bringing my Nigerian
into it that's basically costing
Nigerians and she's born and bred here
by the way right are you starting a
podcast she's born and bred here so what
they're trying to say that they should
call the English now if they call if
somebody says to me oh English woman I
always say oh somebody says where do you
come from as a black woman you don't
even know born here you don't say oh I
come from England you always say oh I'm
from Barbados or I'm from Nigeria Mo I
say like 90 of your black guests that
come here are actually born in the UK
but they don't say that well and I think
it's not normal to say that you're
you're black British unless it's in the
form and I think it's a common like
second maybe third generation thing
because like I'm so far removed like I'm
mostly German Irish like Lithuanian well
yeah like those but further up but
further back they would have said oh I'm
from Germany just say American yeah but
I put myself in her shoes I'm like okay
if I was if I was from like so I would
say I don't I I don't even like this
word identify the most with I grew up
with German nannies yeah so I kind of
know about them yeah true the most and
if they said like this degenerate German
woman I wouldn't say that's racist yeah
you just say that's what you want
if he was
she shut her mouth and tried listening
and let other people speak she obviously
don't understand it
I'm not bring my guest on and I see I
didn't bring her on she came on like
derogatory comments and I actually read
it out to my guests but you know she's
gonna read it out it's printed up that
the super chats are going to be read out
before the show starts it's all there
don't chew gum go to the toilet now
switch off your phones don't move down
the mic and then Pearl stands up and she
always tells you about the super chats
you know they're going to be read out
but because she wasn't shown in a good
light that's why she's upset and she was
shown in a good light she wouldn't be
upset and some of them are really nice
yeah and the thing is like oh there's
some nasty ones have you yeah when I
when I go off on one on the rare
vacations and you know I stood by it I
think I apologize once because I
realized like I did go over the top but
yeah but um overall like they can be
really nice too and sometimes they're
informative and the thing is like
there's just so many super chats that a
lot of times I don't even that's why I'm
so bad at reading them there's so many
and I don't even know what I'm reading
half the time sometimes I don't even
clock it until after I read it and
occasionally if they're really bad I
might I might skip one if they're really
really bad but that's like oh you will
wound them you warn people like you know
I'm sorry like I've seen the super chats
I'm gonna read them but you know
especially the young ones you normally
like say like don't affect you and I'm
really sorry but you know this is what
you say but it's not me you always say
it's not me and and the other thing is
like to me I just feel like if people
will be like oh it's about them like I
think they're gonna say so you know it's
about the money but it's not about the
money it's about that like I know that
the people watching like a lot of times
this is the highlight of their day
they've been working a 40 50 60 hour a
week job and they're still choosing to
give me a Super Chat because they think
that I'm going to read it and I feel
like like am I gonna take away money
from the average person like okay if
they go crazy far and I and I actually
clock it before I read it sure but like
it's more about like that these people
are supporting me and sending their
money and I just think if someone is
doing that like especially like they're
average people and some of them just do
it for fun to hear you pronounce this
surname Mr wojowski or whatever his name
is you know the way he gets on putting
it up I watched that one he's I'm gonna
say it to see if she can say my surname
again was it a Russian or German surname
yeah and he kept on saying it but she
knows what it's all about guys you know
you know them guys that you're saying
that's reading them comments they're
your biggest followers do you need them
what are you gonna do comments and say
yo don't come out you've just hit the
point no but you've just hit the point
yeah I will start a podcast because I
want to change mindset not for money I
don't do it for money Paul is doing it
for money two different things and she's
pushing the narrative which is toxic for
society I want to benefit men and women
so we get along and we have a better
life she wants to push this narrative
and make this hate wider can you tell me
okay now this is the funny thing now
technically it's the girl next to her
it's not her but okay I want to tell you
something that happened Auntie Jenny so
oh you kind of you kind of know this but
I'm gonna tell I'm gonna tell everyone
blessing buckle up Kobe buckle up so
girl on the left apparently doesn't have
a podcast girl on the right has a
podcast now she invited me and Auntie
Jenny on now let's let's be wrong me and
Auntie Jenny get more views than these
girls will ever get in their lives I'm
not gonna lie about to use my followers
for rubbish because they were they're
gonna they're gonna follow or they're
gonna watch that podcast if I appeared
with her just say what I've got to say
and not only that she knows about
podcast
etiquette right but yeah when we watch
this listen to how listen and listen to
how they're going to treat us and how
why they want us to come onto their show
you'd hear it I'm females
but okay so she says it's not about
money right so why do you want us on
your podcast she said I thought it was
about conversation well if it's about
conversation we can have one not in
front of the camera if it's about
conversation she'd learn to shut her
mouth and have one when she's on the
podcast and two and two so what I said
what I said because why would I reward
you for bad behavior I again I'm very
thankful to the people that helped me
early on there are people especially
early on like daily on that podcast like
he helped us move when we moved into
this new apartment he helped us do it
and there's a lot of people that like
did stuff like that that I'm more than
willing to help um I went on I can't
remember the name but there's another
like smaller podcast in London I went on
and
I'm more than willing to do that but
like you're gonna trash me and then
expect me to go on a podcast for free
when typically I have a large fee that I
charge people and I only don't like if
you're one of those people that I feel
very grateful to so I said okay let's
let let's let domino effect make the
money we won't do it on my podcast I'll
offer you my studio let's let's let that
podcast make the money off of it because
it's not about it's right it's not about
money for them and they they call they
call Eddie and they're just like oh
convinced her to come on convince her to
come on like no we want it on our
podcast well if it's not about money you
should you should do it on Eddie's
remember it's the best didn't I when I
when I agreed I said that then she said
oh can you come on my podcast I said I
will go I will meet her I mean
Miss I don't know I'm a woman I miss I
will go onto the Domino effects podcast
with them but I'm not willing to go onto
her podcast so I'm not avoiding you
she's like talks about it about what she
said no like you're saying she it's a
toxic podcast what's toxic about it
I'll tell you what okay let me tell you
something yeah I came from a marriage
right and I had to separate from my
partner for a part wow like say why you
separated him from She's separated from
her husband because he might cheat not
because he cheated because he might
cheat and the longer the conversation
went on the more she changed it and now
she's on this podcast she's changing it
again separate right and I said for the
sake of my child we're trying to
co-parent and heal our relationship hold
on are you on the show yeah now now let
me land let me land I said because of
situations
[Laughter]
see now she's made herself look like an
idiot because they didn't realize she
was until now she's mentioned it the
guys on the left are like oh yes I
remember this clip
slightly contradicted
what I'm saying is me saying that and
I've said I've gone through my trials
and tribulations right and I didn't
realize how hard marriage or whatever
was and plus the Western culture
influenced me in a certain and this is a
culture yeah this is this is what modern
women do like they they want to paint
the story in the way that they're like
even when they it's weird even when they
take accountability they like don't
they'll be like oh well it was the
culture that influenced me and I Did It
For My Child because it's what's best
for my child and it's just like no
you were a selfish modern woman that put
yourself before your kid she's talking
about a culture this is a woman that
grew up in a hat was it 16 children
because her husband dad had two wives so
I think there was like 14 or 16 children
but yet she's talking about her culture
and going on social media I'm trying to
unlearn that and I'm trying to go back
to what I want to be a feminine
[Music]
woman right so I said whatever I'm doing
I'm going she then told me that I left
my relationship I've she said that she
said that she left because her husband
might cheat we didn't say it she did in
my child's life and I'm going to further
ruin my child's life because we were
talking about the statistics of bringing
up a child in a single parent home I
even asked her is it cheaper to live
together or to live apart she said it's
cheaper if we live together I said well
if you've got a three-bedroom house and
you're going to live separately why
can't you take one room your husband
take one room and give your child the
other room and at least make it look a
bit better also she said she didn't she
did she not to them now that she
actually went out looking for looking
for men she actually said that on the on
the podcast that she actually went out
there on dating apps and she wanted to
try day in and see if she's gonna move
on but yet still she was waiting for her
husband waiting like I think she was
giving herself a break of three years
and I think somebody says that when when
a woman says that she wants to break a
free year she just wants to go go and um
and see what's happening in the streets
well and the other thing is like
she volunteers all this information we
don't have to go back to ever because
she got you got you so much the podcast
and you'll see Pearl said to her why are
you why are you giving us all this
information it's like based on what you
said and then we comment on it yeah and
it's like all we do all I do is hold up
the mirror yeah and and if your husband
doesn't want to be with you it's like
why why and and that means you have to
work on something and it it to get back
to that spot and that's what and you
probably want to tell her to do not have
a break for three years how can you say
I've got to go and find myself and and
he's got to go and find himself and
that's why we said that she seem to got
everything backwards because she got
married then she had a child now she
wants to go and find herself how can you
find yourself when you're apart from
your husband you're working on you
you're working on him and then she said
oh if we get back together in the end
it's like oh we you can't be saying you
want to get back together because you've
been out there looking and the only
reason when you're going to get back
together because
that's why you're going to decide that
you want to go back otherwise you'd be
working on your marriage you wouldn't be
working on yourself you need to work how
can you work separately and then come
together you're going to be two
different people still well and then the
other thing she would talk about and
again guys the only reason I commented
on this is because she volunteered all
this information there was like four
other girls in the room who didn't talk
and and the thing is she would talk
about how she's going to live as a
feminine woman and I kept asking her
like what did you do to be feminine and
she kept giving me these broad answers
that didn't make sense like like a real
answer would be
um that I don't know I learned I learned
to cook like a bunch of different
recipes yeah um I'm actually you know
I've invited my husband like if I wanted
to get back with my husband like I I
cook him dinner on Fridays yeah and
Apollo and truly apology working her way
towards him again all right but she
would just give me these broad ass
answer and the thing is that would
contradict everything she said because
if you're doing this what feminine women
aren't freaking on dating apps and that
Carnival but when she first spoke for
about I don't know it's half an hour an
hour she didn't mention that she had a
child because I remember when she
mentioned the child I was the first one
to say well hang on a minute it's
different now because you've now got a
child you know that makes it even more
reason to try and make it work for the
marriage because you have a child but
she spent so long being selfish thinking
about herself talking talking about
herself what she wants all she wants to
go on dates and she's going to do this
she's going to do that and then all of a
sudden up Pops his child out of nowhere
and we were all surprised that she
actually had a child because as a mother
you mentioned your child especially if
you're a child's at Primary School the
child's young enough you can't come and
sleep you mentioned your husband you
mentioned the ABS you mentioned
everything and then eventually it slips
out that I have a child and everybody's
view changed after she and she couldn't
handle it and then and then she talked
about yeah I'm now a traditional woman
and I would just be like okay I'm sorry
you cannot be a baby mama because I you
cannot be I'm sorry you can't be a baby
mama that's at carnival and I'm just I'm
just reading back what you
volunteered who left her husband because
he might she or maybe she said it was
you know she kind of she doesn't she
said my I always remember that she said
mine no I said I completely started by
saying that he said like that because I
I think at first she kind of made it
seem like she left and then later when
she started to look bad she like
switched it yeah and that was the whole
point was like and I don't God only
knows I don't really care because she
even said that because her dad had
another word had two wives that if her
husband turned around and said you know
I want two wives she could have worked
with that or even thought about it but
what he actually says is that you know
she said oh would you do this and he
said well you know it turns out that he
might so she left her husband because he
might but yet she contradicted herself
and said that if he said he wanted
another wife like her dad she would have
thought about it because that is not off
the radar for her have being a second
wife like you and Jess going off
statistics though I don't care
they don't care about statistics because
I understand statistics you need all
right
before everyone speaks guys we're all
content creators
and he's talking to you two in the
middle and he's talking to you two in
the middle and this is the thing on that
podcast I remember ending it and
thinking I barely freaking talked yeah
because this girl and and this is one of
my weaknesses as a host is reigning in
these crazy guests that's why I need to
join you sometimes I know I know we
should do like Wednesdays or something
yeah let us know let us know in the
comments what day yeah
let me let me finish yeah with the
statistics I don't care what statistics
she wants to put me in I'm not a single
mom who's got no education I've got a
full Masters right I've got a full no
one cares you that doesn't mean you can
raise a better child old and what I what
I went off of was the fact that you you
said you were at carnival you you said
that you're a single like you always all
the information you volunteered there
was like three other girls on the
podcast there was another single mother
she didn't volunteer any of this
information about her baby daddy and you
know what's not feminine going around
telling your business on a podcast yeah
that is so if you're living as a
feminine woman and you're chatting all
this [ __ ] about your baby daddy like
does that that's not what feminine women
do but the Africa hardly said anything
and also there was a girl on there that
said that she don't care what she says
that as she goes to Carnival as a single
woman she's looking man then there was a
girl that said that because the girl
said to her no I don't believe you if
I'm going Carnival as a single woman I
know what I'm going for I'm going to to
look for a man and oh no no bloody
degree in politics as well international
relations right I did my thing I've got
my whole career and I went into a
marriage I had my child things didn't
work out I'm not a statistic my child is
yes you are you're a statistic come on
you're a statistic they're telling you
you are a statistic you've made yours
she could have been a statistic of you
know happily married women with you know
nice family with a child that is a
statistic that is a good one she don't
want to be the single parent statistic
but that's what she's made herself and
if you don't want to be it don't be it
go back figure it out like get on your
knees and beg beg say you'll do whatever
it takes to bring the family back
together she didn't say we wouldn't have
known no I know and like if someone told
me okay because I'm trying to I put
myself in her shoes you're a statistic
you're between like you're one of the
women between the ages of 25 and 45
that's single I would say yeah and I'm
trying to work on it but she didn't say
it like yeah I'm trying to work on it
she's like in denial oh oh
starting wife school go subscribe yeah
it's kids you can meet right all single
parents say that that's that's what
they're about to say yeah does not ever
go without my child will never also go
with that so you can't say that I've
just but she goes without her dad half
the week or her mother you can't say she
never goes without and I think that came
up when you said that you would that
your dad was already there you'd rather
your dad was there she said her dad was
oddly over there but her dad was hardly
ever there because he had two women to
service right and all these children but
and the difference is your dad was at
work so his bed was in the house he
didn't sleep anywhere else he came in
the house and that's why I was saying to
her that even if they moved in with the
husband I mean she's living somewhere
else and he's got a three-bedroom house
how does that make sense well and and
even with my dad like there is still
there's something about knowing your
dad's coming home yeah even even if it's
super late or even if he's out of town
for a week like there's something about
like you're waiting for your dad to come
home or you're like a little mini
Christmas yeah yeah yeah and it's like
you're you are a statistic and you can
try to deny it all you want but you look
delusional and that's not my fault all I
do is hold up a mirror to what you said
get mad people might separate people
might have children in different
circumstances because they're now single
doesn't mean they're ruining their
child's life because it might be you're
not single that's the whole point you're
still married benefit that you're not
single you're married alone mother two
parents have to separate that's not what
people are saying we're saying that
holistically and I love Eddie he's
always the man of reason at least
speaking that when a child is taken out
of a two-parent home you don't put them
in every statistical disadvantage of
that kid which is what Pearl said
um that's not to say that you're not a
good mother or you can't raise your
child properly that's just saying that
most women in your situation end up in
situations where the kid goes and that's
fine
you can say most women you see the guy
who left he's like which is why you fit
into this
she don't want to fit and do you and do
you let him talk no did you cut him off
again
but then is she gonna land then we're
generalizing you though in it you're
asking us you're saying no you don't
want to be in a category but then I'm
putting you in a category
my girl let him talk out of there no I'm
not saying that my child's Dynamics
especially me and her father my child
doesn't know that we've separated she
doesn't see that we're not together
right and I say this because when he
does come he'll come we'll do things as
a she never mentioned any of them she
never mentioned anything about the dad
doing anything together and picking him
up and him having her one day and she
never know the other day she never said
anything yeah kids aren't stupid
and this is the thing this is the thing
okay the truth comes out eventually and
I swear to God I believe this with my
heart and my soul one day your kids will
grow up and they will talk and how will
they talk about you your your kids will
grow up and they will talk and
especially in this day and age they're
they're probably gonna have their own
podcast about you if you [ __ ] them up
they will watch this what are we talking
about the kid knows that their parent
that his parents are not like everybody
is his friend's parents and maybe I mean
who knows maybe the kid's too young I
don't know how old the kid was five yeah
it's right they're in preschool they
know my grand my granddaughter came home
and spoke to her parents and she was
absolutely disgusted they weren't
married she said to her dad why didn't
you marry my mum my friend's mum and dad
are married what do you mean you're not
married you take me to school dad do you
bring me home you're supposed to be
married she was really annoyed and she's
trying to say that kids don't notice at
five and my granddaughter was absolutely
fuming why won't you marry my mum what's
wrong with my mum why wouldn't you marry
my mum and her mom said I watched the
head I think you should marry my mum I
can't believe that you're not married
but your mommy and your daddy you're
supposed to be married and she reckons
Eric he's not gonna find out he'll go to
work I'll say he's gone to work or I'm
working and he has her right does he
live there no he doesn't live there but
we live 10 minutes away from each other
she's now it's 10 minutes away she never
mentioned the distance she never
mentioned she just said they lived
separately and 10 minutes that 10
minutes walk 10 minutes drive 10 minutes
by the plane she's still trying to land
yeah but she won't probably won't notice
now but she's going to noise and when
she notices hopefully we might be and
this is what I said on the podcast we
might be in a situation where it might
work out right no she never she says
she's giving it three years which means
that her daughter will be eight which
means that her daughter would have
already known that her mum effed up her
life already so you can't say that oh
we're gonna work things out and then
we're going to move in together and the
girl ain't gonna realize that eight
years old she will know if you if you
really like I'm just like I'm trying to
put myself in her shoes right so if I
was with a guy and maybe there was
something that I did like maybe maybe I
was too jealous or I was too something
like to the point
um that he left and it was something
that I genuinely did like I swear to God
I'd be breaking my back like like
and she's overweight men value you being
in shape yeah so so like I swear to God
if my ex-husband and I and I and I
genuinely wanted him back it like I
genuinely felt like that was the best
thing for my kid and like I don't know
what she's doing I don't know what she's
not doing maybe maybe she's doing some
of these things but if she was a show
but it's not showing because she's not
doing it yeah okay I can say it she's
not he's not doing she's not doing it
it's I'd be I'd be in the gym okay first
of all I'd be I'd be trying to look so
good this is you know what this is game
this is game if you want to get your
husband back this is what I would
recommend I'm not saying this is work
come on um go to the gym right too I put
myself in therapy yeah I wouldn't even
I'm trying to think of how do you work
on jealousy like being less in therapy
might help you therapy would it and you
need to learn to dress properly I'm the
I'm thinking like
um also I would be learning whatever his
favorite meals are I would say what do
you need honey what like what would make
your life easier and I would genuinely
ask what did I do wrong and how can I
fix it is it fixable and I and maybe he
just doesn't think you're serious
because that's what you call working on
it she's working on it and I bet she's
larger than when she left the marriage
because if she's larger when she left
the marriage how can she be working on
this so she's not she's just being
selfish she's going out there and she's
wearing the ring when it's with you know
she's using like she's got these
different hats the lone mother hat that
I'm a single woman working on myself and
I'm the married woman oh yeah I've got a
husband but I still want to go out there
and find somebody else because that's
what she's not telling them that she's
working on it but yeah she said on the
podcast that she was out there looking
and I I feel like too I feel like
getting in shape helps with being
jealous I don't know if this is just
just because I feel like part of
jealousy is being insecure that someone
will take your yeah you know and so it's
like it makes you less jealous when
you're like I'm high
man somebody made my manual eyes and I
thought you know what like f that I'm
gonna learn to make jollof rice myself
like it's not gonna happen yeah you know
and if the best way to get over like
jealousy of somebody else so if you
think somebody that's gonna fancy I mean
if you've got issues work on it
I can cook jollof rice now and now my
mind don't need to go nowhere else
because you know what African girl uh
you lost out I learned to cook it you
know and that's what you do you work
towards it you've got a bit of toning up
I need to do and I've had people
complain about my flabby boots but I'm
old and I can't wear a bra because of my
back so yeah flabby boobs but you know
what I've got a man happy with him it
might work but if he doesn't if it
doesn't we're still in a good
environment and my child will I will
then be able to have the conversation
say especially if we're not moving on
she doesn't need to know anything other
than this is her situation you were
moving on you said you're on dating apps
when if I move on and introduce someone
I can definitely have a conversation and
say look women need to stop that stop
introducing other men to your child
you're a married woman and the child
that you said knows it's Daddy are you
trying to like bring him up in your
dad's culture where he's got two wives
because otherwise why are you going to
turn around and introduce your young
child to a man don't forget about what
if you can't work on yourself work on
your child don't work on finding your
child's another father figure this is
what's happened me and your dad are not
together that's right here's the caveat
though yeah there's not one woman that I
know he's a single parent I'm again I'm
not saying this is YouTube Just to be
that clear there's not one woman I know
it's a single parent that's going to
tell you that her child isn't doing well
every single mother will tell you that
my kid is happy about me in this
situation my kid is there
do you remember I was doing a podcast
and we was talking about crazy mothers
and I said to you here my son would say
that and I think he was shocked and I
said yeah he would say that I'm a crazy
man because sometimes I was and he knows
that yeah my mum's crazy and I never
ever said that as a single parent I
could never ever say that my son was 100
happy because he never had 100 life you
know if you have a hundred percent life
then you can say yeah you're 100 happy
but he had a father missing and that was
a major especially for a child
especially for a boy so I weren't gonna
go around and say oh yeah my son's
completely happy no my son was okay with
the how the life he had but there was
always that father missing that would
have completed it so she's rolls up and
you've heard you know what it is
then you start seeing blah blah blah oh
well you know I raised my kid to be a
good kid blah but when you use a
statistic back then now she's just
saying I'd also like to say that most
kids develop um between the ages of zero
and three and I have some experience
with this um just because I've seen like
my parents adopted and
um I have a friend that adopted two boys
and one was under the age of three one
was over and one I ended up like
stealing money from the church and like
doing a whole bunch of like crimes and
like he doesn't really get along with
the family and the other was like a
gifted musician and all this stuff yeah
and it just showed me that even though
like under five you don't really
remember like one just because they were
older they really couldn't influence as
much even though they grew up in the
same house with the same values under
really really great parents but it's
like a lot of the damage that you do is
before the age of three I had I had to
fuss the child like that and because he
was so damaged I just knew that he was
like a little ball of anger I'd love to
know how he is if you're out there Josh
but he was a little ball of anger and I
think his system out with me you know
via internet some social media and it
turned out that oh then they both had
bad lives he was still really angry and
he was angry at her for putting up with
all the abuse that we're getting so
nobody could he's out there nobody could
because he's always like nobody can mess
with him whereas she you know she was
doing modeling and she was doing this
but she was very Placid and they both
suffered tremendous abuse but nobody
could believe that a child that young
could react like that he used to swear
like a trooper you know he used to cry
he said I said you know and then you
want to cry I'm not going to stop you
from crying he still got the back garden
and sit down and cry and a neighbor said
she came up and she said oh you know I
thought that you used to be you mustn't
beat kids he wants to cry so let him cry
it's his privilege yeah he wants to cry
and then she went out there and asked
him what he was crying for and the words
that came out of his mouth it was all F
this you old woman and mind your own
left in business at three years old and
it does and I've been a foster care and
I've I've studied Child Development and
what she don't realize that all the
stuff that her child needs now growing
up and developing developing she's not
giving that child she thinks that she is
but she's not because it's more than
just meeting your dad sometimes
sometimes it's like smells Sensations
you know like you know Dad's aftershave
in the house or your dad coming in and
giving you a kiss good night or was
sneaking down and watching your parents
you know things like that things like
that help a child's development and
she's actually a child could be really
good academically and effed up
emotionally and socially before a child
used to be shy now you hear these
children oh I'm socially anxious what
the hell and that's what she's raising
no but I didn't do that as well most of
these women don't even know so like when
I'm talking about the man I grew up with
the ones that got lost in the streets
and all of us like come home our Auntie
yeah everyone good everything and then
now you're going there men's coming out
young stuff are doing what everything
about boys
yeah boys are different because they
might go prison and your woman your the
girls are on streets yeah well the women
the women will just be yeah that's why
they say daddy issues are you mad
but this is going to say in British
terms are you mad crazy I've been here
too long with that bro you're funny
huh that's what you need to learn funny
funny because I said that on the show
and somebody said they hadn't heard that
in about 20 years religion culture have
a big influence in my child right that's
rubbish well no I'm
you got divorced and that's what I said
okay when she said she wanted to be a
traditional woman she goes oh what you
said I'm not traditional woman I said no
you're married so you still have the
chance of going back to your husband and
being traditional once you get divorced
in my eyes you are not traditional
you're just a divorce woman right okay
I'll tell you I'll tell you a story
about someone that actually didn't
believe in divorce and and actually was
religious so this there's a relative
that I have Catholic okay she was a
devout like you know those people that
they they just like that is their
livelihood she like I've never seen
someone so Catholic and she had a bunch
of kids and her husband was a fireman
and
um he met someone at the firehouse and
had an affair and she prayed to God I
swear to God she prayed to Jesus Christ
for a solution because she didn't
believe in divorce she didn't want to
get divorced he left her and so like
remember this girl broke up a marriage
because he might cheat this woman
actually religious prayed to God for a
solution the side chick died
amen I came home and she stayed with
them and she was with him for like 50
years but even if the slideship didn't
die and she'd moved in she'd never and I
don't think he would have ever divorced
her either I don't think they would have
ever got divorced because he knows her
face so much and she would have been
quite happy with that because all she
knew is that she's not breaking her
vowel she I agree with her you know I
think you get married once and that
should be it yeah but it should be too
difficult and that's what I hate on my
show I just hate it when people cap like
like I just say be who you are and I
respect like honestly like there there
are girls that are complete 304s that I
love I like and because they don't cap
you know they don't pretend to be
something they're not but it's like
you're pretending to be this like
traditional religious woman when it's
like very clear you're not and you can
force some simps but you can't fool me
and I know this based on the words you
said yeah you said not not
yeah okay Faith will have a big
influence my daughter will know that
she's not bringing home a boyfriend
because that's a certain rule that I'm
gonna have why because you know but you
haven't got the rule for yourself you
already said that you're going to come
and introduce your new man eventually to
your daughter so why are you now saying
that it's going to be different she's
going to come the children follow the
parents if you go up to be then would
you expect your daughter to be a mini
sort your life out but other girls will
go to the park
don't go to the park God Is Watching do
you get what I mean what I'm teaching
now because I'm a babysitter now I was
eating outside the place before I was
cheating everyone here let me land right
let me learn
she's gonna land she's still gonna land
we're waiting for this plane to land I'm
saying is people can obviously how you
raise your child especially culture
religion and I'm a British mom our
parents didn't happen when she
Bangladeshi before
she markets herself it's like see they
say no this is what they do it's like um
they Market them ourselves because she's
trying to be this is alleged right I
know they're going to watch this and be
like oh wow she doesn't know me I don't
actually know you and I don't actually
know your life but if I had to guess she
markets herself as like Bangladeshi and
like more traditional because that's
like appealing to men yeah but then
she'll like talk and you're like I don't
think that's necessarily true and then
yeah and then and then she's British You
Can Tell She's British by the color
she's wearing yeah a perspective they
didn't know what British culture was
like so when your kid is growing up here
and you think you can restrict them like
you're back home it doesn't work most
kids Rebel right I've come I've
understood the world I've learned I've
gone out on the world you get what I
mean in the UK I know my daughter's
gonna face certain things and I know how
to manage that there's nothing and she
can't manage it herself but yeah she's
because she's got enough experience to
show her daughter the boss could do his
parents to stop our daughters from
flinging poops I'm not saying I mean let
me know that I'm very clear hold on yeah
it as well you said he's sorry he said
as well I'm gonna do everything I can
let the man talk
s that man on the list been trying to
talk for ages and you know and you know
what being and this is something I
struggle with Auntie and Michelle
because it is my show and I try to
control it but when you're actually and
I don't claim to be the perfect feminine
woman but when you're actually more on
the feminine side it's really hard to
overtalk men you want to let them talk
because that's the feminine thing to do
is to let the men talk but you live as
this feminine woman but you can't even
let the men talk on their own freaking
podcast disgusting the craziness every
motive no I will ask her intrusive
questions like who are you dating like I
need to know everything but you know
what helps what helps oh that's that
okay yeah we hear it when they go in
there with her dad what helps is the
daughter's relationship with her dad and
the reason why I am enabling this
relationship with her dad is because I
want my child to be so secure with her
dad she doesn't Chase man oh so that's
what she wants them so that's why she
wants me to come on her podcast so she
can ask me intrusive questions but
you've already said that you ain't got a
man that you're trying to get in shape
that you want to do wife training you've
already accepted your thoughts you know
you were fat and you go to look I told
you today that your bum looks really
good you know what I mean it's just
getting slim you know she says I should
because I've been away for two weeks and
I bought her some dresses and she
reckons that they're a bit too [ __ ]
they're a bit too slimming and you know
but I'm gonna give her a makeover right
because I've got some lovely dresses and
slits in but no what I'm trying to say
is that you took responsibility for your
your and that's what I don't understand
you must know when you're putting away
when you keep on buying different sizes
you must know why people might be like
why are you tolerating this or why are
you doing this it's because my
daughter's at my Forefront you get what
I mean Pearl no she's not because if you
watch that podcast she spoke and she
spoke and she spoke and she spoke and
not once did she mention her child and
that's what was so shocking and then
people watch that podcast they will see
that she didn't mention a child and then
as soon as I heard that she mentioned I
was the first one to speak and I said oh
well you've got a child whoa this
changes it all then and that's when the
confrontation changes because she was
sitting down there as a married woman
has left their husband because he might
cheat and she not wants it she mentioned
the child so the child cannot be the
center of your life if you don't mention
your child and I'd also like to say the
only reason she's getting this reaction
video right now is because then he was
crazy okay she chose to go on another
podcast and catch it yeah and tell lies
and that's why I won't go on their
podcast because they lie not because I'm
scared or as my mate will say let them
come for me
of course try telling me I'm being
selfish no you are being selfish because
you didn't mention your child you don't
think about your child or you're
thinking about yourself and you're even
allowing or trying to help in this
situation it's because I want my
daughter to have a such a healthy
relationship with her dad she's not out
on the street now but she's saying that
you're being selfish based on the
statistics of everyone else nobody like
a single single mother homes no no but
much but this is so based on that what
is a single mother home it's mainly a
woman that might not have enough to
provide right that's wrong I was a
single parent and I was earning 40K a
year and I had enough to provide a
single parent home is when you live
separately so don't try and make it
about money because otherwise you're
going to say oh but he's giving us the
money where is the emotional connection
where is the the everyday love not the
part-time after school love where is the
everyday Love Money can't replace a
father in the home and that's what these
modern women think they think that money
can replace time with their parents
can't their child might go without my
daughter
no single parents okay
in your house
doesn't live there you're cold parents
okay but my single is a co-parents this
is gonna be like time number a million
you interrupted the man you feminine
woman
this is what I'm saying a child won't
actually have to see two parents living
together my dad wasn't living full time
at my house for me to have an amazing
bond with him he had he had his life
back
if she had an amazing bond with her dad
she would have had her dad would have
vetted her husband before she got
married and she wouldn't have been in
the situation she is now because when
you're close to your dad you can ask
your dad advice about anything yeah so
can I ask you do you not feel like say
you are now teaching your child that
that that's okay like no because you're
saying you want to bring them up to like
kind of have a certain sort of morals
like you want them to obviously grow up
and have a relationship and feel like
being in your family Dynamic look at her
face
every time someone's like making a point
she's like does that point hit him
that's why you want him to see that
every day you're in a loving family to a
certain degree to his eyes you're the
loving family but then when he grows up
and realizes that this isn't true then
what kind of mentality is he really kind
of he's gonna have because you ain't
really you ain't really showing him that
then either because at some point he's
going to clock that well this isn't true
you've been showing me kind of a life or
my life no but it's not that I'm light
it's just that she doesn't need to know
she's sorry no it's fine it's just that
she doesn't need to know every little
obstacle that me and her dad might have
did you get what I mean and she also
understands that like for example
because I work Daddy needs to take you
because Mommy's working so it's not that
she's seeing it as you know she's just
seen it as this is and I explained to
her yeah but when when she's never seen
her parents kiss when she's never seen
her parents cuddle okay all right your
kid your kid grows up and they will talk
and you whatever your sins are swear to
God your kids will come forward they
might not go on social media but people
will know if you didn't if you didn't
treat your child right I'm sorry kids
grow up and they talk yeah family don't
worry about it because Me growing up
with a polygyny household where I had
two moms I didn't know how to explain
that to people because what I saw when I
went to school one mum one dad do you
get what I mean so for me I found it
uncomfortable how do I say my dad's got
a healthy relationship with two women
and we both live together so I found
that hard and I told my child different
families of different mindsets you don't
have to worry about what so-and-so's
doing your family's like this that's it
wait wait so if you said to your child
you don't have to worry about what
so-and-so is doing that sounds like the
kid found out yeah did you catch that
yeah because otherwise why would you
have to explain yeah because I think
she's saying that way a child must be
going to school so she's got to prepare
the child what she's basically telling
the child is that living apart from your
dad is normal yeah well and that's
that's a different family and that's
what kept happening on the podcast was
she kept contradicting herself so then
if I was there I'd say wait wait I
thought you said and then she'll be like
oh she's manipulating I'm like what are
you nuts as long as she's happy trust me
she's good like and I would I would I
would do what I need to a quick question
obviously I don't want to just focus on
your thing I want to keep it wider but
do you know that's what she done on the
show we were having a show and they end
up with over half the show on her
because she wouldn't shut up now look
what the guy's saying let's focus on
something else because I don't want it
to be about your thing and that's what
she tried to make it see that there
would have been a benefit if for her if
100 together but that's why I'm making
my relationship with him that is it
would be better if they were together
100 so rather than stay here together
that's what she's saying we're gonna
separate so that we can get that 100 we
don't I don't add up can be mended if it
works out I can't force him to be okay
okay if it works out you know hold on
right it takes two to tango and that's
what Pearl wasn't did he leave the woman
no it's just that actually we didn't say
that I said to them I blame both of you
I remember saying that when I found that
she had a child I said it's different
now because now you've got a child I
think you're both wrong because you both
need to work it your bow should be in
the house working a so she can't say
that wasn't said and now what about the
man like if he doesn't want it to work
this is something that women always do
whenever you blame something with women
and say that a woman's at fault they
always say what about the man yeah like
sometimes we can just make statements
about women without bringing men into it
yeah there's nothing you can who left
though I'm saying like who it's not that
who left is we answer the question and
that's what you know she said that she
left and now she she's no and that's the
that's she's kind of switching it she's
going around it now then that's why like
people that are if you're telling the
truth you directly answer a question
yeah agreed he initiated it that he
can't yeah
no he initiated it he initiated it by
answering her question you know they're
the conversation he said he might cheat
you know just a conversation he didn't
cheat he didn't like cheap I wonder if
it's because she again I was leaving no
yeah he initiated that he can't do the
whole he doesn't do you know what it is
I think especially because we got
married some men don't like having
someone to answer to do you get what I
mean some men don't because you're not
as a feminine woman you're not supposed
to talk well a man should answer to a
woman like to be able to call someone
and say oh I can't come home today do
you get what I mean yes and what but
that's what I'm saying is and at that
point at that point I didn't understand
no but at that point I didn't understand
that why can't you tell me do you get
what I mean so where now she's blaming
him now now she's letting me know he
done this and he done that he would have
done whatever she never mentioned all
that on the show he felt like I don't
want to have to tell you and I felt like
well you should it was a culture clash
and it goes into the topic we want to
talk about because obviously it's a
culture class but yeah she's bringing up
her child in her own culture and her own
religion but now she's trying to say
that they're different cultures so which
culture she raising their child in for
my race do you get what I mean is she do
raising a child in her culture the
British culture like what she said
earlier the British culture her dad's
culture or her husband's culture and it
can't be it if she stays by herself
she's not raising her kid in her culture
exactly like you can't that's like
that's like okay if I my parents are
both Catholic they can't say they raised
us in a Catholic home if they didn't
stay together Catholics don't believe in
divorce exactly I had a sudden culture I
wasn't saying that's what they got so
many kids because that would even
contraception either
expectation on what I wanted in a man
because of my culture and if you don't
marry the same culture you're not going
to have this was there a reason why I
didn't want to say it all sorry was
there a reason why I didn't want to say
no it's just a little something some
women that I've like been meeting
probably not like that but like some
things I just wouldn't want to fall in
town it's going to be a headache yeah no
I feel like and I feel like I take
accountability there were some things I
could have definitely changed she took
no accountability none how come she's
taking it now I want to hear what she's
taking accountability of I think she
started towards the end of the show but
it was kind of like after we like ran
around with circles for her for two and
a half hours and then yeah there was
reasons why and I liked how Daley tried
to change the topic to anyone else and
it still he was talking about herself
yep foreign
accept the person I was at 23 to who I
am at 29 we're not the same if I know
what I know now we me and him will be
happy living okay and this was my point
on the show was because then she was
like I was I was feminine now and I was
like okay what did you do to get there
and then she knows then what she knows
now her and her husband will be happy
together but you know it now so why
aren't you together she's been working
on herself what she said just now is if
she knew now what she knew then but if
you know now enough to make your
marriage work and you're working towards
making your marriage work why won't you
use that knowledge that you've got now
to make it work well I'm like let me
talk to your husband what would he say
have you changed and and that's that's
the real indicator would your husband
say she's changed
no it's not that he was right I think
both of us were growing at different we
communication definitely was the problem
she accepts the decision
years to accept it but I accept it I can
see what I needed to do for myself do
you get what I mean but you know what
yeah do you see the difference between
this conversation that's been had she's
not insulted because it was like
questions like you're not saying your
relationship is [ __ ] you are she wasn't
there she was on that podcast she was in
a totally different podcast I didn't say
your relationship as [ __ ] and I never
said that we told her to work on it the
thing is she's thinking that we're and
she's making that we're anti-men and
we're we're anti this and we're anti
that we were actually trying to get her
to go back and make her marriage work
that's what we wanted her to do we
didn't say oh no this train that you
need to get together and try and work on
your marriage and if she's grown so much
from being apart why haven't if she's
learned so much now that would have been
helpful for her marriage why didn't she
get to stay with her husband even if
it's in separate rooms and work at it
then it would have worked with all this
knowledge that she's gained since they
split up mother do you know what I mean
she didn't say that's the sort of thing
that person she did I didn't even say
that no yeah uh did she say that yeah
yeah she did say that because she said a
lot of things she said that I was the
one that left and I was the problem and
I'm I remember she said she left now
she's saying the husband left so if the
husband left why is he in the same house
he's in the family home oh [ __ ] I didn't
even think about that he's in the family
I didn't even think he's in the family
huh that's what I was saying to them
move back in oh wow I didn't even think
about that oh wait no I wonder what
Eddie's gonna say did I say that Eddie
you back your corner and say you didn't
no do you know what it is no but that's
what happens no but I like how she's not
letting Eddie respond because he's gonna
tell the truth that's why he did if
you're getting drawn out should I tell
you what happened here is I might say
something she'll then put her stupidness
on
no you said something stupid and then
Pearl said something sensible you're the
one that put your son
like yo how did you get that you know
what Hold Up Wait we got it from you
there were your words that's how we got
it we did not make anything up we used
your own words
again there's a lot of shows that girls
come on and don't go viral for her and
then this woman had the audacity to ask
me to take the stream down
she asked Eddie to ask me and I'm just
like Eddie pay me thousands the
thousands of dollars I will make on
these clips yeah pay my producer pay my
editor pay pay my person that makes
shorts pay all those people because
you're stop it
but she she's never had any pushback in
her life or anything she says and she's
so used to people like women can just
paint this story and no one will push
back on them ever and they're so used to
it that when any ever someone says you
know what you're not making sense this
shocked and they have to rebel and it's
always somebody else's
it was the first time somebody said no
to her or you know we told her the truth
some some of you all some of y'all did
not have siblings to bully you growing
up and it shows it really shows say it
and then obviously while I'm talking for
example Carnival I'll give you an
example perfect example Carnival I went
Carnival she's telling
no we didn't say that she was saying
that she was trying to work on her
marriage and that she went Carnival and
we were saying that no if you're working
on your marriage and you're being a
traditional woman you wouldn't go
Carnival because even somebody said that
you would go Carnival you go when you go
Carnival you go Carnival with your
partner and I said that I've been
Carnival I've been carnivals in the
bands and I also said that as a mother
if you are going to take your child to
the carnival you would go on a Sunday
which is Children's Day safer she said
oh I didn't go Carnival um it was that
it was at the butch it changed to I was
living in Ladbroke Grove and the
carnivals at the bottom of the road so I
just took my daughter down the bottom of
the road so that she can I don't I don't
know whether she mentioned a child but
you can she went down to the bottom of
the road to see Carnival that's what she
said well and my whole point was that
you're claiming to be traditional I did
not say mothers don't go to Carnival I
said additional women don't go to
Carnival but traditional women do go to
Carnival but it's how they behave and
it's what day they go on and who they go
with is this it's a cultural thing and
it's not her culture it's not her
culture so as a Bangladeshi woman you
wouldn't go as a traditional black woman
sometimes they've been going you get
women that 50 60 wearing the costumes
but you won't go out in night you won't
go out in scanty clothes sometimes you
go out in a group of friends sometimes
you might even take a chair and your
picnic and sit down buy a band or sit
down at the edge of the road and just
watch everybody go by but this is a
woman claiming to be wanting to get back
with her husband working on herself and
she said that Carnival was passing at
the bottom of a road so she just went
there to have a look she says now right
I can't
I took my child Carnival and you know
what she's never said all that because I
lived on Ladbroke Grove I lived on the
road that Carnival was happening chicken
was in my doorstep no she's gonna say
she didn't have enough time to explain
it
you talked
now she never said she was in a gay
place she said at the bottom of her Road
watch the podcast I swore before the
podcast Eddie made a joke about her like
shaking butt at carnival like it was
something like
she mentioned something like that yeah I
don't know with my child pick up jerk
chicken and go home even if he wasn't he
never said that she'd pick up jerk
chicken and went home she never said
that she said she went Carnival I was
taking a gun Carnival from five with
like my mum and Dad's life and this is
the thing
you'll go with your parents and if he'd
been going Carnival as a child I want to
know what day he goes on where you go
wrong these conversations here now
because I was there and I was listening
it yeah is that when you don't explain
or provide context fully you find
yourself up you leave people to assume
or try to
um she gave a lot of contacts Daddy just
contradicted her so she just
contradicted herself like 10 times oh my
God
okay and you often did that okay and you
know why for example the comment about
Carnival Eddie made a joke about it
before recording she dropped it in mid
recording she didn't ask me sorry what
took you to Carnival and let me explain
she just said oh married or traditional
woman she said what took her to Carnival
she said what took her to Carnival and
at that time she was looking around it's
really been she said she was on social
media come on how could you be
traditional and are you on a dating site
I'm just curious just like does anything
on this Instagram scream traditional no
this is us so she's in wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
so let me let me get this straight it's
20 22. when did she say she was working
on herself I mean out of contact she
doesn't know what where who do you get
what I mean she's assuming I went there
shaking my ass with everyone but she's
assuming that that was her first
Carnival experience I think I think it
was because Eddie said it before
Carnival once and she saw what was
happening
no because I would never accuse the
majority of men of me tooing me I would
never say they they assaulted me I would
never say that did I grabbed up no
because I wasn't dressed like a thought
that only happens when you're dressed
like a thought
you should get no fools
trying to grab her did she have to say
no to anyone lost women content yeah so
her assumption as if someone is filming
content of what she sees that thing is
I remember this bit now you see all the
things that she's talking about yeah
what she mentioned did this happen to
her did that happen to her that means
that's the norm because she's she's
twisting it and making it sound as if
you were so unattractive that nobody did
she get a dirty wine did somebody
grabbing her so these are things that
she sees that she knows is happening and
she's trying to turn it to take the piss
out of you to say you are so
unattractive that people didn't do that
so she knows what happens at carnival so
why would you go she's saying what
happens okay and that's the other thing
they always that's always their go-to
not pretty enough okay
okay so you didn't get a dirty wine
would you really wanted a dirty one I
know what a dirty wine is what the women
were doing with men behind them or
winding up behind them no the only thing
that happened was I was
um walking back and like there was this
crowd and someone got kind of close to
me but I feel like he kind of clocked
but I was not I was like I swear to God
you grabbed me we're gonna have problems
you can have that look you can leave it
you can build it and kind of was the
kind of friendly place that if you give
somebody like you don't smile and say hi
to everyone if you know that somebody's
getting too friendly a look is enough
yeah sometimes they can tell by your
stance that you're not a carnival person
or you're just a visitor yeah especially
by the way you're dressed but she's she
just said it oh because she's making
that old Carnival was so innocent but
did you get the dirty wine you know so
she knows what happens because she's got
she's good looking I have to get a dirty
one because you know all the men are
grabbing her body don't forget she's
that attractive you're there shaking up
and that's ignorance and grips that's
ignorance and it's offensive to the
Caribbean culture
you can't tell me what's up into the
Caribbean culture you're not Caribbean
sorry you're not Caribbean so can you
tell me what's offensive to Caribbean
culture
but it's offensive should I tell you
some people no grabbed yeah but most
people get grabbed get realizing
different times
when everyone's having a conversation
like this we're always talking about the
majority not the minority yeah tell them
again always talking about that pajamas
but you can't so the majority I know
what I see at carnival yeah and every
man there knows what they said
on me I'm not the majority no no but
then when she said that all you have to
say is that now I went there and I went
home you didn't think I didn't say it oh
why are you always adding your little
like yeah
no no she did she had she did if I said
to her if I said to her I lived on that
Grove she was like oh don't tell us
extra bits now but you didn't see that
though because I did I did that I did
today no she cut me up if you saw it
nobody cut you up you said that you
lived on that Brook Grove and you just
went down the road to watch carnival at
the bottom of the road you didn't
mention nothing about no jerk chicken oh
I just grabbed jerk chicken who's gonna
go to Carnival grab jerk chicken and go
back home come on I've had friends that
lived on Redbook Grove we stayed in
front of the house and watched the
carnival go by you didn't say that all
of a sudden you're living in a gator
Community you popped out you went to get
your chicken and come back you're a liar
yeah and one thing she does as well
she'll be like don't talk I'm talking oh
I'm sorry do you know what and that's
what the men should have said to you
because that's what you've done all that
time so perhaps you would have said stop
as Pearl said stop stop stop stop can
you stop talking when I'm talking and
look what you're doing to the men look
what you are doing to the men you
haven't stopped doing that
yeah [ __ ] come on mine that's so
traditional come on mine you haven't got
one you've really said just come on mine
who's the [ __ ] now [ __ ]
she gave me enough night time is she
stupid no we didn't give you enough mic
time you took it no one could shut you
up you took the my time that when you
come on a show she's gonna shut you down
because you gave her enough my time
you're stupid because you gave her
enough Mike time
respect means not over talking the host
so if you keep over talking the host
they're quite giving their right to tell
you stop stop stop stop and if you don't
stop then say excuse me but can you shut
up you don't over talk the house that's
all you've done all you've done since
you've been on their podcast to say
listen I'm talking now they're the holes
and it's their show
Photoshop she might have cut you up but
she didn't say shut up she said stop
talking it's my podcast
that was so rude of you stop talking
it's my podcast it was because you both
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up
both of you
and on top of that you want me to
explain myself then you tell me stop but
someone I gave you plenty of time to
explain it is not my fault because you
saved yourself you can do a bigger and
bigger hole she contradicted herself she
said that you gave her a lot of airtime
you didn't give it to her she took it
did say you keep interrupting people pal
that person has sent at least yeah now
out of all the comments she found one
person one person that said oh you know
you were doing it as well Pearl you know
one person and that's what she's going
with it you wouldn't know but if you
want to go through the trouble of
starting a podcast getting a producer
getting an editor
um putting a bunch of chairs together
buying a bunch of equipment
um hiring a bunch of people and you want
to have someone and you want to
interrupt me on your show you can yeah
it's yourself that's fine
uh but then had the rest of our cult
following she said I was too
argumentative at every point I was
making was just to be argument you never
said she was argumentative because she
was talking dumb she was just arguing
for everybody said that about she was
just being she was just oh how can you
not know what a woman is of course I'm
gonna argue you are a woman you came on
the air and said you bleed three times a
month look it look it look here I I do
think you're arguing just to argue if
you can't acknowledge a man versus a
woman call me old-fashioned call me
crazy but yeah yeah I stand on that call
me call me crazy if and a lot of women
that go on her podcast they all have the
same experience where are they I do
think that she's I'm sorry wait hold on
anti-woman and I think especially
um if like ethnic women
okay so you're gonna insinuate that I'm
sexist and a racist and then invite me
to go on your podcast but but Auntie I'm
so sexist and racist why why would they
invite me on their podcast I don't want
to racism I I certainly wouldn't want
myself doing a show about races
and look at look at the girl in the
middle who doesn't like the drama and
doesn't want to be a part of it she's
super happy she's enjoying it and all
these girls have the same experience
there is a a good chunk in the London
hate group it's not just them there's
there's a couple there's like two that
threaten to beat me up
um and they come on the show they didn't
have a good experience but here's the
thing like you meet people in life half
of them aren't gonna like you that just
happens that's part of life you think
all the people that come on your show
like you no come on and and this is the
thing it's like so and and there's a
bunch of people there's a bunch of
people that love the show we have a
whole community of people that that are
like friends because of the show no
we're not gonna go you know we're not
gonna say it's in the majority but most
people do like you the majority of
people like her and if you don't like
Pearl why the hell are you following it
if you don't like her why are you coming
on the show if you don't like her why do
you want us to come on your low
prophetic show why
I refuse to go on a show with a woman no
I can't say that
because you don't know what a woman is
a real thing
somebody who believes three times a
month I can't go on a show and you don't
know what a woman is come on
and you saw her mother she is you will
see an ethnic woman there you will see
it it's buried in mind I was doing the
recruitment yeah so yeah I'm coming for
you now they're blaming him now they
blaming him before they were saying that
you brought them onto the show and there
they can see that we don't know who's
coming onto the show Eddie recruited
them
it included them but they approached
Eddie we would like to go on this show
Eddie said okay or vice versa would you
like to go on this show they said yes
how is that Pearl's full when we tell
you that we do not know who's it's very
rare you might get the odd one like
Davina or somebody yeah but occasionally
like one or two or I might invite you
but it's always like a regulars that I'm
friends with that I'll just like last
minute they'll want to come on but I
don't know I don't know who's coming 90
of the time you think I got time to go
through all these profiles at four days
a week oh God you got me [ __ ] up you
messed it up no it wasn't really hurt
nah you messed up it just turns out you
know I was gonna cut you off for that it
just turns out yeah
wow
I literally I was gonna then I thought
you know what it is I'm obviously I made
connections with like
um Cheryl Lynn Cheryl Lynn do you know
Range Rover mom yeah yeah and I've made
a connection with other women like and I
thought you know what it's good to come
out of it again other women that are
crazy crazy I don't know how these
people are personally but like oh
they're crazy without like them she's
got nothing disclaimer she has nothing
to do with Range Rover please don't call
a Range Rover mom because Range Rover
does not like him
okay
she's the one that went to that when
they were protesting she pushed one of
them with her car because she had to get
her kids to school and she actually did
the protesting I'm gonna sit in the
streets and play with himself I only
found out the other day when somebody
watched this and told me who she was but
I don't know who she is you don't want
to know she's has she been on the show
no she's got her own podcast but it's
for women like them oh they're craziest
yeah
um
and then she said she's gonna cut any
off for inviting her on the show
like what I would say here is that when
it comes to like when Pearl and not
speaking and talking about statistics
like you sound like a you sound pick me
you sound like I'm not pick me I'm not
like shame and Tokyo and need to be
right he a man can't have an opinion
without you cutting him off or insulting
him that's how that's how she is sexist
I'm gonna just say this now she is she
is sexist and misogynistic or misandras
misandrist I know my words
listen I don't show there's no one right
now it would be mad
when you're replying you can't reply
with feelings why don't you come back
with a statistic I love their accents
calming them
yeah then do a podcast you know when you
said you want to travel they said
Birmingham oh is that who it was about
half an hour from me oh okay okay okay
maybe I will I mean those this is what
you say well actually this kind of woman
does this and does this don't say oh
well I feel like that's that's not oh
this is
my opinion
something one thing people need to
realize about statistics it's not every
single goddamn person on the world hold
up let me land we know what's the man on
the left when she's trying to land
as a politics student who had to use
statistics in what I've argued right
I've had to even manipulate my own
statistics to suit a certain agenda
right hold up let me land now hold up
when you're looking at UK statistics my
mother has never answered any of these
questions right most of our mothers
haven't these statistics hold up and in
his turbulence statistics
is going to fall down he's saying the
turbulence on the landing and the oxygen
mask is going to fall down
to a certain demographic of people right
my reality especially like just say my
friendship groups Asian African people
very Asian African like we're first gen
most of us are very strong faith in not
Christianity or Islam you're not you
would be with your husband
in your face and leave your husband or
looking at getting divorced I'm saying
99.9 would never cheat because that's we
Fair God right hold up that's my she
never cheated but she was willing to
concern you having letting her husband
have two wives reality of my statistics
right that statistic is still quite
important but you're telling me the UK
women will cheat that's not that's
that's anecdote weeks no no no no but I
could do it I could quantify it didn't
do it but this is what I'm saying I can
quantify it no one's just had time to
quantify it so the statistics that's
like for example the one that you used
about credit consumer credit where I've
worked as a financial investigator
Consumer Credit who does it impact the
most it's not ethnic women it's not just
credit it's women women on two-thirds of
Consumer Debt we also own the majority
of student debt
um and we also are higher on default for
like paying rent we're higher on default
for for credit cards or higher we spend
more even though we make less like it's
multiple stats it's not just one usually
it's because those countries don't have
policies it's usually a policy what
should you want to say is that you're
talking about like UCO America and what
she wants you to do she wants you to
take all the black people out of it
should I list all like every country in
the world and go through let's say
Antarctica there's not many people
that's what she wants Randy women of the
UK English women just say yeah my mom
has nothing about credit right yeah so
you're consistent about single moms on
credit that generally speaking yeah
they're not are kind of women
so what I'm saying is when a woman
especially a woman who's a single mum
depends on consumer credit and making
them a lot of them come who've got drug
addictions they've got other significant
conditions that's a lot of rubbish
because a lot of single parents can't
even get credit you can't get credit
she's making it sound like you can just
go and get credit
it's like the working people that are
getting the credit it's very rare that
right then you might go to loan sharks
and stuff like that but she's talking
rubbish that are impacting them right
bad decisions they make it but they've
got they might come from severe like God
knows what else yeah but they make
stupid decisions based on their
lifestyle okay yeah that that's that's
true she made a stupid decision that's
true women do make stupid decisions
based on their lifestyle they spend more
even though they make less look it and
you cannot blame the world for you
making dumb decisions because of your
trauma
men don't do this and Men I would argue
that men experience more trauma than
women the world is very hard for men and
that's what a lot of women don't
understand we are born with beauty and
youth and that goes away at some point
and but the thing is like the world is
here to protect you like men are always
looking to protect women and they have
this innate like thing they're nicer to
you because you're a woman and and the
thing is like women we will never know
what it is like to be a man and to be
treated like a man and they don't even
make excuses for the [ __ ]
there's black and Asian women that are
single mothers and their culture and
Faith have made them different
population in the UK is black and F or
only 12.
statistics where should you get those
statistics from She's shouting at
numbers no no this is against stats
that's right and I don't disagree what
you're saying yeah it represents such a
small fraction of the entire exactly
that it's irrelevant to the main topic
but that doesn't take
but they could wait but that there are
women so when I'm talking about my
reality that's because my reality of
women are my statistics of women I don't
go for the UK statistics I go for what
my women are like yeah
but you came on my podcast why would I
why would I talk about why why would I
talk about what she said she's
Bangladesh Bangladesh e women on a show
in the UK run by an American
and because of you guys I'm going to
quantify it so women ethnic women come
out do the surveys
yeah say your last points we have to
ride that stuff oh yeah people already
we're gone what I was going to say is
that like what you're the only the only
thing we can do is get statistics and as
well a lot of the statistics that I said
they're not normally The Narrative so I
don't have a reason to skew the day if
you get me of course they do if I do a
study on oh uh what do people like for
breakfast and I want to Target I want
McDonald's to be the best answer I will
go yeah is what I'm saying so what I'm
saying is when we're talking about now
but independent people do that so they
will okay but when we look at who owns
who owns the world's Consumer Debt but
the thing is and they can put in her
women it's you can't really you can't
really
you can't you can't really f up those
stats Here Auntie you got to talk in
your mind sorry traditional Bangladeshi
women the husbands are in charge of the
money the husband deals with the money
so that they they won't be going for
credit or anything like that so when she
says oh yeah the Bangladeshi women you
know that my mom never had a credit card
no because your husband was looking
after her that's why she never had to
have any credit and if you have all
those children he's got two wives he's
looking after the family so if there's
going to be anyone that's going to get
credit it's always going to be the men
because traditional Bangladeshi
traditional English traditional Asian
women the men are the lead of the
household they control the money so of
course her mum never went and got credit
because the husband looked after a fix
so if anybody's going to go and get
credit it'd be the husband Paul get
certain area groups that they know are
the most the rice arrive they're
peer-reviewed studies they've actually
had to go for a peer review it's not
like
you see your face every time someone
makes a point look at both of their
faces
studies I can't believe this woman has a
master's degree no no no no no no no no
I've star rated on a scale yeah
every study has a reason why they want
to find out something yeah hypothesis
but exactly doesn't mean you're biased
towards no it's not that you can find
out what the hypothesis is not avoid but
you can then modify it because for
example if you can just tell daily so
much smarter than her oh yeah and she's
what's waffling now she just keeps
saying words uh the poor parts of London
you might get McDonald's the best answer
you might go to Chelsea and you'll get
bloody girl do you get what I mean the
fact you've done statistics you know the
whole thing about statistics and
obviously I've done a lot of it from
from my job is reliability and validity
the validity doesn't do what it's
supposed to do reliability how often can
it be retested and get the same answer
yeah it is a good study and it's
reliable that point you've just
mentioned is yeah
but you need to change the demographic
if you're going to say okay sir I am I
know you're gonna watch this
you're not feminine I'm sorry nothing
about you is feminine he the guy on the
left tried to talk
remember when I said before that it
seems like it's easier to get a degree
than Common Sense she proves me right
yeah so to me you need to include my
culture my faith
if I say women are worse with money in
general
and you get triggered that's your own
damn fault English physics with that
how'd you know that Auntie Jenny's very
good with money she has a she bought her
house in cash she's very good with money
but she doesn't get triggered because
she has an IQ of more than two I swear
to God I swear to God no because because
you know women in general aren't good
with money I'm not a big spender I'm the
only woman in my family that's good with
money yeah yeah and I learned that from
my mom but all my sisters no none of
them are good with money of course it
didn't because the UK population six
percent of us is that little can only
get so many so either way the statistics
are correct no they're not
unless you unless you do it every single
person
that's the plane people is Just Landing
he's a comedian I go to your guys's
podcast
that's
which is fine and then bring the other
ones that's fine
that's why that's what Pell does a lot
so she does
[Laughter]
you use a lot of Statistics we didn't
know that what what an Eddie does that
Eddie
I'm trying to say so you saying like
once like certain statistics but you're
not looking at the other side so out
like we had a discussion about how
um men and women so about she was saying
that men don't actually have a lot of
sex and I was saying actually they do
because they have lots of like women
a small fraction
statistic that she was relying on she
was saying like 30 of men have not
actually had sex however statistics
shows that men have multiple women like
double of what women have you're wrong
no no but what I'm trying to say is the
point is if you look at different types
of Statistics it's going to see your
arguments but if I say yeah men are more
likely to have multiple women that's
facts that suits my argument the whole
minority of men we're all men here
can I give you a fact now but we're all
men here and we know there's man in the
group that never got nothing in fact we
know that animals man you know when he
goes he's clearing up you know that the
point is the men that are having sex
they're having a lot of women the
statistics not talking about that okay
it's not talking about that okay it's
about looking at the bigger picture yeah
and the bigger pictures
we're talking about baby mamas and then
she was like oh yeah not actually to be
fair they're not really having that much
sex I'm like yo what there's a lot of
men having lots of babies no the
minority
guys
now the host is trying to shut down the
show they're still over to talk in the
house and she claims number podcast
etiquette and she's still over talking
him and she doesn't even understand
statistics the men are they're talking
and telling you that this is what the
statistics say and she still wants to
argue she's got nothing to argue about
but she's arguing the men she just
expected that because she knows them and
they're her friends that they're going
to agree with her but men don't want to
look stupid they want to tell the truth
they don't mind you know you want to
make yourself look stupid you go ahead
30 percent I've not had sex that means
seventy percent have had sex right it's
double of men of double of women are
having multiple women that's a lot of
men no it's not having them they
probably just had sex within me yeah
I like the guy they're both funny he's
funny
Let me let me drop it assistant
how are they are still in the air
okay this
isn't showing that one in uh one in four
one three
I'm not quoting the statistics but I
just want to show you an example like
one in uh one in four Asian men get
stopped in search by the police but it's
one in two black men right that's it
it's more black men are committee hold
up no no wait let me finish let me show
you that no no no no that's not why
that's not why no no no no
hold up
they're more likely to be stopped and
such obviously they're more likely to be
arrested it doesn't matter anymore
no it means that they're focusing on
them a lot more no I mean they're
committed okay let me explain now yeah
hold up
daily daily daily
because I'm not gonna lie you won't pass
as a typical black man getting stopped
and such under that you look you could
pass as more Asian anyway but let me let
me land anyway now she's saying that he
looks Asian but yeah she was saying that
she that she don't know Bangladesh you
want me to see this the next minute
she's at now she's saying that black
girl looks Asian take down the
statistics further it's more Caribbean
men that are stopped at just say one in
one in two right then African men are
stopped at one in four but that makes
the statistic go higher right Asian men
Indian men in Pakistani are hardly
stopped but it's Bengali men that are
stopped at one in four same rate as
African men yeah
no no it's not that no it's not that
it's because it's because of how we look
we look darker we could pass as black
right so when the police see us when a
racist police officer sees us he's
seeing us as you must have black in you
do you get what I mean but people don't
talk about how when if I was to now say
Asian men Bengali are suffering the same
rate as an African man people like
that's why the statistics on shoulder
but they don't actually break down and
show that it's the Indian that's making
it look like it's one in four Asians no
but you could break that you could break
down statistics like that with
everything people could say oh who's God
but you're gonna then undermine the
Bengali man's sufferation because the
Indian materials they've been trying to
wind up that show for the last how many
minutes
they've been saying even the guy he's
not saying we need to wind it up Eddie's
been looking but we need to get out the
studio we need to wind it up she's so
feminine she's trying to land
listen get in stopped yeah
I think the next episode we should react
to the comment section yeah because that
comment section got heated oh yeah and
we should do
um the part on the other show that she
was complaining about the the uh am I a
woman what's a woman no and she said
like the church thing but that's what it
was all about that's the one when she
said she went to China and came back and
then she it wasn't religious and I said
I think your faith was weak we should
react to that next show yeah we should
um thank you for coming on the channel
auntie thank you it's a pleasure as
always
um also I'd like to say um to the girls
in the video I would have done none of
this
had you not made this video you gave me
something to react to so when you
complain which I know they will be the
victim I can see it coming right
um
You Gotta tell the truth I'm not gonna
do nothing until you came for Auntie
Jenner
actually that's true and that's why she
decided because I said no pearl we have
to do pills like no no no and then when
you came for me I said how rude I was
and I wasn't I can be and then when you
came for me that's when Pearl decided
you know what I'm gonna do something and
I said no Paul we need to do it properly
because I want to make because
everybody's talking and nobody can see
what is actually said because I the way
they were behaving I thought that
protocol a degenerate Nigerian I didn't
because I thought I can't remember
saying that and then somebody said it
was somebody in the comments that said
it so then when she came at me lying
about Auntie Jenny can't come for Auntie
Jenny no you can't leave Auntie Jenny
alone she's my aunt yeah yeah so you
can't come first that's true that's true
that's true but but I will say we
wouldn't have done any of this if you
didn't do the podcast to begin with so
and I know they're going to be the
victims now blah blah blah
but look at you gave me something to
react to today which is kind of fun like
I always say if they want me to
apologize I will I am really sorry that
we're using our your own words against
you
but come on your show I won't but
domino effect shout out I'm Eddie and
Daley the only caveat is you cannot talk
over Eddie or daily yeah that's my you
know interrupting them
they can't do that they couldn't do it
on your show and it's obvious they can't
do on that show they were worse on that
show than they were on yours I know I
know because at least you were saying
stop stop stop as I said that you said
shut up I would have said shut up but
you said stop stop stop I can't see us
appearing together but we're willing to
do it this is what I deal with but
anyways like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and we'll talk to you
next time as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible